lead the pledge please thank you
thank you
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
thank you and good morning everyone i'm
representative michael bose of epping
and as chair of the house science
technology and energy committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing actually an
executive session of bills referred to
the science technology and energy
committee
please note that there are no physical
location there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i confirmed that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has has access to
has access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary
access information has been available
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website
notice for this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
ledge.state.nh dot u s
in the event that the public is unable
to access this meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
assisting us today from the house
committee staff is jennifer four the sde
committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
we will start
the meeting by taking the roll call of
attendance when each member states their
presence
police officer also indicate whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
mr clerk please call the role
representative thomas
here in the committee room next to
chairman bones and next to the open
window
representative harrington
i'm at home uh my wife's here wandering
around somewhere
representative
i'm here too far away from the open
window
here in the committee room next to the
representative
president and committee representative
president
representative white i'm here at home
yeah he had to present to bill he'll be
in late
i'll accept that
representative kelly pitts
i'm here can you hear me
representative
[Music]
i see you he's connecting
present i'm in my office alone but my
husband and son are in the house
representative vincent
i'm here i'm at my home
yeah i'm home and in my office alone
representative
i am by myself today present
their
here in my home office alone except for
a snoring dog
representative
i'm present in the committee room
i would just say for um representative
mann it's star six to unmute on your
phone
it looks like you can unmute on the
screen as well john
[Music]
okay thank you everybody so today we're
having an exec session we will be
exacting eight bills
and
we will not be exacting them in the
order that they are listed in the house
calendar
but
we will exec all eight bills
it is my intention at this time
to retain seven of these eight bills
we'll discuss each one in turn
but we're going to start this morning
with house bill 315
and i am going to move
the adoption of amendment
2021-06
six four h
this amendment was sent to
the committee this morning
it came from
ols and it corrects four typos
i will read those typos
on page 2
line 26
we inserted the word with between
on page 3 line 12
we change
the text to read
fails to meet the requirements
unquote
on page 3 line 34
we deleted the words
of the customer's application
they were superfluous words
that deletion was
agreed to and endorsed by
the honorable clifton below
and then on page five line 23 we removed
the word
may
which left behind the word shall
those were the typos that we
asked ols to correct and this amendment
[Music]
h recognizes representative thomas
um
mr chair i'm just uh doing something
here right now
the uh
there's email from jennifer kerry
uh that was titled uh
oh never mind
that's a different bill 6106 these
emails are coming in yeah
okay um chair i move to uh
adopt the second of
0.6658
4665.
okay it's been moved in seconded that we
adopt amendment
zero six six four h is there any
discussion representative medina thank
you i just have a question
i remembered on page two
uh
let's see where is it starting on uh the
paragraph under financial responsibility
on line 23
that there was some discussion about the
incidental costs not being written up
properly and i'm just wondering if that
was changed it looks like it's correct
do do you remember
mr bilo went into an extensive
description of how there were some
incidental costs that might come along
with a town moving towards
um
a community power program that would
that basically the exception was for
capitalized and operating costs not
being transferred onto ratepayers who
didn't want to participate
is it isn't that what this paragraph is
about
yes you are correct and the discussion
uh that did ensue around that issue
determined that the text was correct as
written
it's covered by the
text online
29 and 30.
yeah which may include okay all right
just wanted to be sure because i thought
there was something that had to be
amendment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion to adopt
page
representative thomas
yes
[Music]
six
welcome back representative
yes
representative mcgee
president
yes
okay uh and i'm chairman bulls
chairman votes votes yes representative
mann now seems to be back at least he's
on screen
representative
you could have known someone
yeah
is it legitimate for a person to vote by
doing a thumbs up
if they have no audio maybe
here it is
he can put his thumbs up and he sounds
you're visible i don't see why not all
right i'll put it down
representative man would you if you can
hear us would you
give thumbs up or thumbs down on for
one big face up there we can't sleep
he's gonna hit
okay
okay by a vote of 19-0 the amendment
passes
so i now move
ought to pass as amended on house bill
a second
okay i recognize representative callie
pitts
thank you representative
all right it's been moved in second that
we
house bill 315 otpa as amended
is there any further discussion
[Music]
seeing none
john mann can you
give me some kind of a verbal
i mean a visual signal about whether you
can hear us or not
apparently he can't hear us
can someone that knows to never call him
i'd like to leave his quote impossible
can
jennifer call him at home
and give him give him the phone number
to call in
the phone should work
i'll try to reach out to him um if his
phone line is free but it did he was
connected well before so maybe he'll be
able to sort it out but i'll try to
reach out to him thank you
okay thank you
so much for the big screen and point to
the space or something
mr clark
yes
my understanding was if there was
technical difficulties that the meeting
suspended is that correct
members of the public notify us that
they can't get in we have to suspend the
meeting yes no i'm i'm i'm talking about
members of the committee that if there's
technical difficulties that the meeting
has to be suspended
i don't know how we get to him to hang
up his phone so somebody can call him
yeah we tried to reach him but the phone
line's busy i know because he's trying
to be on the number he might be on a
wrong number
the introductory script says in the
event the public is unable to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled
it doesn't say anything about
anything about the members
it doesn't say anything about members of
the committee being unable to
access the meeting
so
we'll try our best
and encourage those of you who know mr
he's in the middle i don't know if
anybody just left the room during the uh
while the vote was called but i saw
somebody moving around
actually there he is
he's
there's something wrong with the
equipment in the room do you guys need
something
what do you want to say i'll do it hang
on
[Music]
does he know what he's voting on is the
question
he has connected to the meeting
representative man if you can hear us
press star six to unmute
you better eat some of that chocolate
yay
here yeah he's connected to me here on
the side
here
[Music]
you need to unmute him john he's on the
phone there i'm not able to do that he
needs to press star six
okay star six john you're still on mute
your phone is still on mute star six
as amended
thumbs up thank you thank you can you
talk thank you john
you can hear somebody so the vote is now
20 is there
yes
representative harrington
trying to get designed yes
representative daughter yes
representative
yes representative
representation yes representative
bernardi yes representative
yes representative
yes representative white
yes
please
to 0 the
hp 315
passes
otp as amended and thank you everyone i
genuinely appreciate that and i also
extend my thanks to all the people who
contributed
to the amendment that allowed us to
produce
this successful outcome representative
without object this bill on consent is
that anybody object i do
i object because i think it's too
complicated to matter
okay
i will not dispute that it'll go on the
regular calendar but there will be no
i agree with you jackie thank you thank
you
all right so with that we'll close the
exact session on hp 315 and open an exec
let's see let's do hb213
next
and the chair recognizes representative
thomas for a motion
thank you mr chair uh i'm a motion to
representative thomas moves to retain hb
213 representative knotter is recognized
for a mode for
a second i second the motion to retake
thank you it's been moved and seconded
that we retain hb 2 1 3. is there any
thank you mr chair i understood from our
discussions on friday that there was a
possibility that we'd be hearing an
amendment uh from representative thomas
that would replace this bill with
something that we could all support
uh
but what happened with that
we were here to discuss that with house
leadership
and uh because it would be a non-germane
amendment and because it is a study
commission
uh they advised us to do that later in
the session
we'll just retain the bill now and we'll
probably amend it later or possibly
thank you
representative mcgee
i guess i'll ask the question for the
other issue that came up when we had the
work session on friday which is the sort
of damocles hanging over the industries
that are worried about this bill going
through as it's written and
we had discussed or i had brought up the
idea of itlling it in order to remove
that because we won't be able to act on
it until the new year
so it would be um
you know from all the outrage that we
had from the timber industry and the
forestry industry and all the folks that
told us that they would not only lose
jobs but might have to close their doors
uh i know we didn't pass the bill but i
think just having it out there as is
without
um
any relief for those folks that are
concerned about it is is an issue that
we should consider like itling it rather
than
retaining it because right now it
doesn't seem like we're doing it for
anyone in particular that it would
benefit
thank you for that comment i will remind
you that
one of the reasons we're retaining some
bills
speaker reiterated that in the chairs
and vice versa this morning
so we have to basically put off
sadly
issues that are going to be
controversial enough to generate
affordability
and hb 213 falls into that category
uh representative pementel is recognized
thank you mr chairman uh not that you
need my vote but i would be uh
inclined to also vote to retain if you
gave us some kind of reassurance that
that would be
uh a bill that we would
take up in the spring
so we could talk about the amendment
then
and
take that sort of damocles
off the table
so if
you could give us some kind of
reassurance that that might be one of
the first bills we could
take up i know you said that we
would be able to start talking about
retain
could you respond to that please thank
yes i will i
will reassure you that i will make every
effort to take this bill up in this
spring i can't guarantee it but i'll
make it for every effort to make sure
that that happens
representative grecian
thank you mr chair um just going back to
cat's point about taking the sort of
damocles over people's heads
i would suggest if we could unanimously
vote to itl today and get it on the
consent calendar then it wouldn't occupy
you are correct but as i pointed out a
it would engender a floor debate and we
need to discourage floor debates
for the rest of this session
thank you representative harrington
you're recognized yeah first of all it's
not going on consent if it was put on
there i'd take it off and second you
know you talk about industries with
assorted damocles hanging over their
heads well any industry that lives off
of rate pay or taxpayer subsidies is
always susceptible to losing that
subsidy they don't have a right to other
people's money it's a bill that was
passed to give it to them any bill that
the government passes to give somebody a
subsidy the government can take away and
they've got to realize that when they go
representative
mcgee is recognized
thank you mr chair
i i appreciate
representative harrington's perspective
and i've heard it before i i guess i'm
looking at
the people who came and spoke to us and
the people who submitted testimony which
i think is our job
we had one person in support
and we had 366 people saying this is bad
for new hampshire so i'm asking who
we are supposed to be catering to
in terms of other decisions that we make
because if they're going to up end the
economy that is supposed to be a value
that we all share that we're responsible
for not making those kinds of decisions
that will upend people's livelihoods
with no real justification and that's
how i see this bill is it's quite
damaging to a number of people but
there's been no there's been no
justification for why we're doing it
other than an ideological predisposition
that opposes renewable credits
um so i
yes i agree with you that people who
receive
programs may not always want to
make may not uh
be in a position to expect that they
will always continue but there's also an
expectation by the public that the
government will not be capricious and
arbitrary in decisions that upend them
and that's
the other end of this which is what is
our reason
what you know there there's been no
justification given one person supported
this bill
once again i will remind you that
processing of the house's activity
is an important consideration here
representative creation you have your
hand
i apologize that was from before
okay representative platt is recognized
when you're looking for a subsidy you
show up looking for the subject
the general public the general rapier
public doesn't necessarily show up
because they're interested in thinking
as well
and so this is something i think there's
something in 213 the original impetus
was because some plants are closed
and so although they will use that so so
there's something to be salvaged in here
and still
to protect those who got on the gravy
okay
anybody else
seeing no
further hands raised i'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the motion of retain
[Music]
representative mann i just uh request
that when you hear your name called you
well it's not your turn yet
wait until we call your name
okay i also have
this we can hear you now
yeah
i don't know what happened
we can hear you
wonderful i've been working on it
okay
yes representative
yes representative white
yes
professor
representative uh man
no
did you say oxenum
yes sir
no
thank you
observe dancing
[Music]
no
okay
represent
oh representative votes chair chairman
what is your question representative
representative white is he in the in the
i could not see him all i can see all i
could see and during the vote was
abraham lincoln
i'm right here
i thought we had to see him visually are
you
all i could see was there's a telephone
on the bottom and that confused me too
because it went green but then i saw his
face
okay
looks like so i know it's him all right
he's here all right
certainly before okay
okay it's 1471.
discount
the motion to retain passes
we'll close the executive session on hp
and next we'll open executive station
executive session on hb14
the chair recognizes representative
thomas
i want you to retain mr chair
[Music]
thomas
vice chairman thomas has moved we retain
hb 148. he recognizes representative
nader
i motioned second the motion to retain
hp 148. representative knotter seconds
the motion to retain hp 148. is there
i can't
hear i'll i'll pass for the moment i'm
still trying to find the bill thank you
if if you give us a heads up of what the
order is that we can be ready when when
you turn to the bills
my apologies i'll try to do that thank
you
hp 148 is allowing increased net energy
metering limits for municipal
any uh
seeing none
i will ask the clerk to call the role on
the motion of retain
for house bill 148.
uh representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
yes representative yes representative
yes
representative
representative mute yourself
representative mick williams you appear
to be muted
and we need her video also
can you hear me now
yes
answers no
i vote no
okay that's him
[Music]
yeah
okay by about 18 to 2 with one member
voting
that's correct
all right so we'll close the executive
session on hb 148
and to give all the members a heads up
we will take up the
remaining bills on the calendar in this
order
next will be hb 394 establishing a
commission to study
the short and long-term impacts of
pending national and regional carbon
pricing mechanisms on new hampshire's
residents
agriculture wildlife and natural
resources based tourism sector and
commercial process
then we'll take up hb 172 which is
staffordshire which is about
establishing greenhouse gas emission
production goals for the state and
establishing our climate action plans
then we'll take up hb 167
relative to net energy metering limits
for customer generators and the purchase
of output
of limited electrical energy producers
then we'll take up hp 153 which
establishes a committee to study
universal internet access for new
hampshire
and finally we'll take up hb 106
establishing procedures for municipal
most customer generators
called energy so that is the order in
which we'll take up the remaining bills
so now we'll open the executive session
and
we're not
announcing that
earlier in this
in this session
[Applause]
we're going to make the next session on
hb 394
establishing a commission to study the
short and long-term impacts attending
national
and regional carbon pricing mechanisms
on new hampshire's residents agriculture
wildlife and natural resources based
tourism sector and
enterprises
or recognize anybody else for a
discussion i will
point out that i asked the speaker this
morning
at the
vice chairs meeting
if
the
advice that we were given at the
beginning of the year
advice to retain all study committee and
study commissions because the senate
would
them if we pass them here
if that advice still stood and he said
yes that advice still stands
so
i recommend that we
retain this bill otherwise if we pass it
it will get killed by the senate
so the chair recognizes representative
thomas for a motion
uh mr chair uh
promotions
representative thomas moves that we've
retained hb 394 the chair recognizes
representative knox i second the motion
representative nodder seconds the motion
of retain on hb 394 is there any
i'm wondering what what possible value
taking up the time of the committee to
discuss it is if if this is the uh
preordained conclusion is that it's
going to be retained
i i i i think you know in one sentence i
think we all understand that
universal access to broadband is
important in the 21st century as rural
electrification oh no no that's the
wrong bill this is carbon pricing
wrong build hp 394
i'm sorry i tried to write down and
order the bills as you gave them to me
carbon pricing
this bill is
wrong
i'm the one who's wrong here we are on
hb 148.
394 we did 148.
did we do it was retained 18 2-1
yeah okay okay
so i was right all right and the
broadband bill is 153 so let's not even
that's right this one's until the end
394.
thank you very much um
again a an extraordinarily simple bill
setting up a commission that would
simply prepare
new hampshire for what's coming
regional and national carbon pricing
massachusetts connecticut rhode island
our neighbors are moving forward
we are part of a regional pool i think
it makes complete sense that we should
do this
understanding that this is going to be
retained i will close my comments there
thank you mr chairman
um
you know i i think things are changing a
lot quicker than
uh what was originally thought
uh
in january when these
rules came up
that
retained bills will be
itled
i
i know that other um committees are
going ahead and
and
passing
uh commission
and committee bills
and um
i don't see why we shouldn't especially
if we can get bills out of committee
on to unanimous consent i think that if
we could do that
uh we're going to be limp that'll take
care of the debates
during the legislation session it'll end
up going to committee
uh on on the other side of the wall and
hopefully they can uh
do the same thing there but i'm i think
we need to take a
thank you bev and tell i would uh remind
you that uh another goal of retaining
bills is to avoid floor debates
so it's possible that a bill such as
this might come out of the committee
we're trying to avoid that and so
that is another reason for you to
consider
representative man you're recognized
i agree with
representative pimentel i'm going to
thank you representative count you're
recognized
i'd like to ask what the implications
of
house bill 373 which i am
violently opposed
and this bill is our des
still going to be able to talk about
carbon initiatives and what they are
because somebody's got to be watching
the store
i think the federal my opinion is that
the federal government is going to move
much faster than
we think
i think they've put on the railroad
tracks and i i think that we need to be
abreast of what's going on
so i want to know if hindering
discussion
in the dea in des is going to stop us
from following these issues at all if we
postpone this committee which
i think somebody's got to stay abreast
of the issues and and
keep the legislation brief so that's my
question i'd like somebody's opinion
well i will give you my opinion if you
would like it
i would
my opinion is that hp 373
was confined to a fairly narrow
issue of
initiatives involving
transportation
whereas hb 394
is
regarding a much larger issue that
actually is a national issue more than
a state issue
so
i don't see the two as being
connected very closely together
and i see no reason why we shouldn't be
representative
yes thank you very much uh the the point
of this commission is to keep
new hampshire abreast of what's
happening at a regional level and the
national level with carbon pricing and
to be prepared for that so that we can
be proactive in making sure that our
economy transitions in the way that's
most helpful to our residents and
businesses so again it's a very targeted
issue
about carbon pricing but what it's about
is monitoring regional and national
trends so we're prepared
okay thank you representative
another thing to take into consideration
here is i don't know if any of you had a
chance to look at hb 2 yet but
60 pages of the
budget trailer bill
is involved with a description of the
newly proposed department
not
so i don't available any
compelling need for us to do anything
with this bill right now other than
retain it
and we can probably rest assured that
the department of energy will be looking
any further discussion uh representative
mann
yes i i
i would agree with i didn't say much in
the previous time i agree with lee and
uh disagree about the department of
energy i do think the legislature and we
need an independent
uh study of what the national
very likely national level um
carbon pricing uh would um have on our
economy on our small businesses and so
on i don't we don't know
um you know
it's not an obvious thing and i think
we owe it to our people to study this
and again um
i can't imagine the senate uh voting it
down despite what they said because it's
got to be clear to them that this is an
important issue
thank
you thank you uh
appears that representative samson is
now
thank you mr chairman
i hope you had success with your other
endeavors this morning
to bring you up to date on what has
happened
we uh
passed
an amendment to hb 315 and then passed
the bill
otp as amended
with no votes against
we
retained
hp 213 and we retained hb 148
and we are now discussing discussing a
motion to retain hb 394.
following this bill we will take up hb
153 and 106 in that order
thank you
you're welcome didn't we do one i'll
sing
excuse me uh representative callie pitts
i thought we did 106.
no no no
okay any further discussion uh
representative oxen of your hand is
still up is uh
you want to say more
yes thank you very much i i i'm
surprised by by your position that you
think that this is going to be handled
most effectively by the new department
of energy it seems to me your position
in the past has been that you want
policy made in the legislature not in
our agencies so i i think it's very
important that we should have this uh
commission available to work with the
department of energy going forward
okay thank you representative
you mr chair uh
i'm starting to hear
repetitive comments i'd like to call the
vote
okay representative thomas has moved the
question
see no further hands raised i asked the
clerk to call the role on the motion
so the question has been called
oh yes uh jd bernard
okay we've been in the voting mode
all right so the clerk please call the
what is your question if the motions
would be removed and the motions could
then be remade so that representative
but he was here when the question was
called
so he can vote
preacher
representative
peter you need to unmute if you're
speaking
sorry uh i i'm not sure about that since
i might i brought up my
my video later after i got on so i'm not
certain about it
i would appreciate it if we can clarify
if i'm a voting member or not at this
point
i
will clarify it because we faced this
identical issue earlier in the session
and i had a discussion with the clerk
about it
you may recall that
representative notter was out of the
room when we opened an exec session on
an earlier bill i don't remember exactly
what bill it was
but then she came back into the room and
we suspended the exact session because
we didn't think she'd be able to vote so
i went and talked to the clerk about it
and he says as long as you're in the
room and present when the question is
called when the clerk calls the question
if you are in the room
and present at that time then you can
work that is correct you missed the
exact session discussion you can still
vote
that is correct but the question was
called wasn't it that's what we were
discussing the question and it had been
called am i correct mr claire
no you are not correct
fine
then somebody's got to make a motion
thomas to retain
house bill 394.
so i'm not calling the clerk to call the
roll
it was already seconded jackie by by
janine
i know that the emotion was made and
once a motion is made if you're out of
the room the same thing happened to
representative harrington okay he was
out of the room he wasn't present the
motion was made and once the motion is
made you're in the voting mode that's
all that's the parliamentary procedure
whether the executive session is called
or not that has nothing to do with it
it's whether the when the vote was made
the motion was made the motion was on
the floor
that's all and
mr chairman can i just uh suggest
instead of wasting time about discussing
this could we just kind of
rewind this a little bit and start over
again it probably saves more time than
yeah you're probably right okay so
representative thomas will you re
withdraw your motion to retain hp394
yes i will just throw my motion to
retain
i'll tell a second
okay it's been moved in seconded that we
that
representative thomas withdraws his
motion for retain on hb 394 i don't
think it requires a second
now i will recognize representative
thomas motion to repay
second
representative thomas moves and
representative knotter second motion to
retain hb 394. we've already had a
discussion on the bill
it's now official that representative
samsic can vote so i'll ask the clerk to
call the role
representative thomas yes president
yes
yes representative white yes
sir
now
representative
okay by a motion by a vote of 11 to 10
the motion to retain hp 394
passes
and it demonstrates uh why we need to
retain these
we don't have a broad agreement on that
i'll close the exact session on hp 394
and now open an extension on hb 172
recognize representative thomas
recognizes
representative knocker i second the
motion to retain house bill 172.
it has been moved and seconded that we
retain house bill 172
which is a bill that establishes
greenhouse gas emission reduction goals
for the state and establishes a climate
action plan
thank you very much mr chair i apologize
for having broached this one out of
order
um
when i tuned into the meeting this
morning there was a substantial
discussion going on between the
republican members in the chamber
about um
the religious adherence of many in
democratic members of this committee to
the issue of climate change and i i
would just like to point out for the
consideration of the members who
seem to feel that this is an issue of
belief rather than of scientifically
demonstrated and proven fact
constituting and
a crisis situation for our nation and
the world
that the united states chamber of
commerce in the past week just put out a
statement
of position on their approach to the
climate issue
saying
that we recognize
excuse me not we
us climate policy should recognize the
urgent need for action
while maintaining the national and
international competitiveness of u.s
industry
and ensuring consistency with free
enterprise and free trade principles
this is an issue we must deal with our
constituents are asking us to deal with
and i hope that we will not
simply put it on the shelf and retain it
representative callie pitts is
recognized
i i personally don't think religion
belongs in this but being a religion a
theology major i don't think there's any
religion
or any kind of group
in the world that does not
advocate stewardship
and taking care of the environment and
that goes back 10 000 years because
i think that that's universal whether
there's a crisis or not that's debatable
but taking care of our environment and
seeing that we keep it
as pristine and as as clean as we can
i don't think is debatable across any
group
thank you
representative
sausage
thank you mr chairman um
i would just like to suggest that if
there is any religion in this committee
it should be the religion of science so
um regardless of what religious faith
you may belong to
i think we need to put science in the
foreground of our deliberations here
that is the duty we have we are the only
institution in the state
that specifically deals very deeply with
these issues
and we'd be well informed and we should
be willing to listen and we should be
willing to articulate what we think is
the best for our our state and our
citizens thank you
thank you representative representative
pimentel
thank you mr chairman
um
it would be nice to think that we could
achieve great things without goals but
i seriously doubt that can happen
this is a bill
which
establishes goals or works towards
establishing goals
and
i i think that this is a bill we should
not be retaining we should be otping
this
uh so that we can
uh make the goals so we can reach the
thank you uh representative thomas is
recognized
well thank you mr chair i just wanted to
state that
i agree with representative kelly fitz's
comments as they were stated and i don't
believe anyone here
we advocate being poor stewards of our
environment in any way i think the issue
is one of methodology
and i believe it's complex
and i believe that's why we need to
retain
these types of bills for
a lot more discussion because it's not a
thank you representative man
yes um
i'm reacting to the all of the other
comments um
[Music]
we can't just sit here and do nothing
and in addition to everything else and
all the other good reasons for doing
this climate action plan and really
taking this issue seriously
there's a lot of jobs
at stake
the
lower class the working class people
take a shower after they go to work
instead of before
you know are losing jobs left and right
and working on
climate mitigation
transportation issues buildings issues
could provide a lot of jobs and i i
don't see
any downside to having a climate action
plan that that it's intelligent and i
think it's a very good thing for all of
us thank you and and by the way
i have grandchildren that have to live
in the future and i take this personally
i really think we
i need to say that
thank you
i said don't forget to unmute you are
recognized
oh thank you
i appreciate it as a co-sponsor on this
bill um i just thought i should
uh mention the fact that
uh i think one of the reasons that the
bill came forward is that we have spent
the last several years
in a place where we haven't moved
forward in terms of goals
and i do understand that in sb2 there's
additional definition coming as to what
a department of energy would be once one
is reinstated
[Music]
but i think that the legislature has a
separate obligation as was mentioned
already which is why i was in favor of
seeing this bill there is a lot of good
information we could pull together
fairly quickly just to
be able to have goals
and then everything else would come from
that and it just makes perfect sense for
us to do that which is why i i am very
sorry to see delay delay delay on things
that really are just essential
good policy for any state to have so
i just wanted to throw my two cents in
because i i really did think that this
was something that's time had come and i
didn't think that we would have a
partisan
you know that there would be partisan
perspective on it if you're actually
looking at what's going on in the larger
world
thank you for taking my remarks
i just wanted to mention that uh the
prime sponsor representative weston had
uh attempted to bring forward an
amendment that would have changed
des to the department of energy but
because the department of energy does
not yet exist ols was unwilling to
entertain an amendment that would have
changed that
should the bill go forward i believe
that the senate would be um
it would certainly it would be useful to
have it in the record that we approve of
that change to the department of energy
okay good point
see no further uh discussion on
the question of retained
house
bill 172 i asked the clerk to call the
uh rope is there a thomas
yes
yes representative
sausage
no
representative kelly tips yes
representative man
no
representative
[Music]
no representative mattel
no
representative
what is it
i have a vote of 12 to 9 the committee
votes to retain hp 172.
i'll close the exact session on hp 172
and open
relative to net energy metering limits
for customer generators
of limited
electric
house bill 167 the chair recognizes
representative niner i secretary mccain
representative not her second motion to
retain on house bill 167 is there any
discussion
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of retain for
house bill 167.
okay
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
yes representative yes
yes
[Music]
no
um
by a vote of 11 to 10 the committee
votes to retain house bill 167
i will now close the executive session
on house bill 167
and open an executive session on house
bill 153
establishing a committee to study
universal internet access for new
hampshire
and recognize
representative thomas
mr chair of the motion to repaint
representative thomas moves to retain
house bill 153 representative notter is
recognized
i second the motion to retain house bill
it has been moved and seconded that we
retain house bill 153 establishing the
committee to study
universal internet access for new
hampshire
fear recognizes representative thomas
thank you mr chair um although we
motioned a motion to retain this i think
this is a very important bill and we
learned this morning uh and our
earlier meeting that uh
we might be able to put together an a in
committee
subcommittee to discuss how we might
want to present this bill when we take
it up again later on this spring or
i would i would
offer that that might be something we
may want to consider
i'm sorry that was breaking up and i i
couldn't hear
the representative's remarks
okay representative thomas could you uh
move a little closer to the mic over
there and try to repeat what you're
writing
yes
what i said was i'm very interested in
this bill
uh i think it it needs a little bit of
work and i but we did learn this morning
that if it's something that we could do
in house
meaning within this committee only uh it
may be possible to have our own sub
committee to work on something that we
can bring forward when we take up this
bill again later on the spring or
possibly in the fall so i would i would
uh representative sausage is recognized
uh thank you mr chairman uh i i also
agree with representative thomas this is
a really important bill
and if um
if we are assuming that by retaining it
we have the opportunity to work on it
and get something done
i would be very much in favor of that
too
thank you very much the issue of a
subcommittee seems to me to be different
from retaining but i'm not really clear
of the boundary line could could you
give us some clarification uh mr chair
as to how this a subcommittee
could work with how we would have to
vote in order to proceed with the
subcommittee
uh
well a subcommittee is something that we
could establish if we retain the bill
another option is we could establish a
subcommittee
before
without retaining the bill
however if we did the latter it would
require that we
complete work on the bill
work
in time for it to come up before the
regular house
which will be sometime in early april
so uh
i don't think there's time to do any
significant work between now and then so
i suspect the best we can do here is to
retain it
and work on it later
uh representative thomas is recognized
yes uh thank you uh just to add uh to
that question um also we learned this
morning that if we do something in-house
within this committee as as
subcommittee
the biggest difference is that
we we would not have any senate
representation on any subcommittee but
we could still work on it amongst
ourselves here throughout the remaining
period and come up with uh perhaps
something uh that we would might be able
to work on when we take this up against
that that's the biggest that's the
uh representative oxenam do you need a
follow-up
trying to process our
our upcoming schedule it seems that
we're going to have about about a month
of hiatus between today
and the three days of marathon on i
believe it's april 7 8 9 there's
something in that area
um
i agree i wouldn't want to to set up a
situation where we had to complete our
work by that time but if we could
again ask the chair for an assurance
that he would do everything in his power
to make it possible for us to advance
with this and use this month that we
have available to us to actually begin
work on something that is of such
importance to our constituents
perhaps we could come to an agreement on
this
well i'm just looking at the
first page of the house calendar
of friday march 5th
which was um
last friday and the first page says that
pursuant to house rule 67
after discussing the proposal with the
majority and the minority leaders
the speaker has decided to alter the
scheduled deadlines
and
he
changed the last day to report all house
bills
to april 1st of 2021
today is may uh march 8th
and april 1st
i believe is about
21 days from now
i'm not sure that that would give us
a new
universal internet access for the state
of new hampshire
it's establishing a committee to discuss
it but what i was asking was if we could
use this time to begin that work to
okay uh
yeah that's a reasonable request however
i can't guarantee that we can do that
because
we were also told at an earlier meeting
today that senate bills will start
coming to us very soon
and
even though we're not at official
crossover yet we've been advised that we
should start deliberating on these
senate bills
so
uh
it'll all depend once again on room
schedules and
the available availability of zoom
licenses the the house only has five
zoom licenses so that limits the num the
number of meetings we can have on any
given day
so i can't
promise that we would do something on hb
we'll try to squeeze something in but if
senate bills take precedence and we
might not
might not be able to do anything but if
we retain the bill we'll certainly be
able to do something later
uh representative plett
you have a comment
not anymore okay representative mick
thank you very much chair bose um i just
i want to note something for the record
um
i'm frustrated hearing that
house
leadership
is claiming the senate will not pass any
study committees or commissions um
i've been checking in on senate bills
and i just want to note for the record
that uh senate bill 71
was passed
ought to pass
as amended establishing a commission to
develop science-based emissions
reduction goals for the state of new
hampshire so the senate is passing
commissions and committees
so i really take
i have some concerns about claiming that
the senate won't pass those and i want
okay thank you
i can only tell you what i've been told
by
seeing no further discussion on this
question
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the motion to retain house bill 153.
representative thomas yes representative
harrington
yes
president
representative
yes
yes representative campbell yes
representative
yes representative white
yes
where is your man
no
purple
yes
no
mcgee
yes
no
[Music]
having voted 17 yay
foreign a
the motion to obtain hb153
passes
the executive session on hb 153
and open our final
session today
on eight
thank you thank you for the cheer um i
motioned to return that
106.
representative thomas moves to retain hb
106 representative knotter is recognized
i second the motion to retain house bill
106.
it's been moved and seconded that we
retain house bill 106. any discussion
representative mcgee
yes thank thank you mr chair
um my understanding is that we have
three count them three amendments to
this bill which means there's a lot of
interest in trying to get it done right
um
are we sure that we're retaining it
without discussing or accepting any of
these amendments is the way we want to
go
the retained motion has to be uh
judged first we can entertain additional
emotions if retained
representative kim grills is recognized
i have a similar question if we could if
you're allowed to retain it without
having to look at the amendments or pass
the anonymous post
yes it is correct that we can retain the
bill without entertaining
amendments which might be
apropos
and then is it true that if the retain
motion fails we would be able to
consider the amendments
for a new motion okay thank you
any further discussion
see none i'll ask the clerk
representative callie pitts is
recognized
i guess i want to know what the
rationale is
we understand that there are
are
cities and towns that are ready
to do some of this
and that when we
postpone this or retain it
we are putting off their planning
they're purchasing
in this reopen new hampshire atmosphere
right now
and
i don't think that that's a wise i think
thing to do
the governor at this point is saying
be open get industry going get
everything going again and we are
honking that
by putting off some of these bills
the earliest we can bring these retained
bills back
correct me if i'm wrong is next year
and so we have put things off a whole
year for people who can't afford to have
things put off a year
i think that we could reach a compromise
somewhere if we worked at it i don't
think that there's a push to retain it
today we have until april 1st to see if
we can come to a compromise on this
i think that we ought to just put on the
brakes
and say let's see if we can work
something out we know there are projects
ready to go projects mean jobs jobs mean
money
money means
people are are backed into purchasing
and they're off the unemployment rolls
so i think that's that's all the goals
besides efficient power and sustainable
power so i think we ought to see
in all
honesty if we can work this out within
the next few weeks by honest discussion
we've seen what discussion can do and
how it can bring us together
on things we never thought we could come
together on
i don't think we've given it a fair shot
at honest
downright discussion and i i think we
could do that i think this committee is
more than capable of reaching a
compromise so i i really do believe that
and i think that retaining and putting
things off for a year
and probably more than a year
in this especially in this atmosphere
where things have been put off for a
year already
i think that
we are doing a disservice
all the citizens of new hampshire and to
pers and to our governor and
who wants to get things going again
okay thank you i would remind uh
everyone here that we have two goals
here
one is to decide what to do with these
bills and admittedly
some of them have promise and
future deliberations of this committee
made churn out a bill that's acceptable
to everyone that is definitely a
possibility and retaining doesn't
preclude that possibility
but there is another goal here and that
goal is to
allow the orderly process of house
business
under very difficult circumstances
and those circumstances are that we're
only going to be able to meet
two or three more times in full house
sessions
before the april 8th crossover bid
and we're gonna have to process a huge
number of bills during those two or
three
house sessions
i don't know about you but i didn't
particularly enjoy
the session we had last year where
we were working on bills at 3 30 in the
morning
and i don't want to have to do that
again
and the only way we can prevent that
from happening
is to avoid
floor debates
avoid bringing forward bills that will
generate floor debates
and
i know for a fact in talking to members
of my caucus
that if we bring forward hb 106
as is or in a modified version
it will likely generate florida
whether we
pass it or whether we kill it
and so in order to avoid that outcome
i personally think the smartest thing we
can do is retain house bill 106
and then try to come up with a
compromise that we can all live with
at a future day
uh representative pimentel is recognized
thank you mr chairman it's
11 30.
if we could
have a discussion
on some of these amendments
maybe we can get to
a compromise bill that
would go to the legislature
on the consent calendar
so why don't we give it a try why
why uh retain it
and
uh just push this out into the future
uh while people are waiting for this
uh they want us to
do something
and i think that there's within this
committee
some reasonable compromises that maybe
we could just be able to move forward on
representative mcgee is uh recognized
thank you mr chairman
i definitely appreciate what you said
about the house sessions and how we're
trying to limit
limit the um you know the floor fights
and and the amount of time that we need
to be together for voting i think that's
a that's a realistic um
you know goal for for leadership to try
and figure out how to limit those floor
debates but we are going to have floor
debates so i think from our committee we
should we should have been determining
all along what are the most important
priorities that we're trying to get over
the finish line
and for the folks who are new on both
sides of the aisle i just wanted to
mention that
um
this bill you know the idea of raising
the net metering cap is not new right it
keeps coming back um usually up to five
and we had passed it with a veto proof
majority and then it was vetoed and then
the second vote on overturning the veto
what you know there was a whole bunch of
wrangling going on all through the
summer and everything and you know when
it came back for a vote um it wasn't
overridden but the fact is it's about it
has bipartisan support because so many
representatives
are working in towns where they are
being told by their leadership we need
this
so i don't think this is one that we
should gloss over because we're worried
about the extra amount of time it might
take for us to have people discuss their
thoughts on the floor that's always a
problem and we can have that on lesser
bills but this is not a lesser bill in
terms of
people around the state um asking for it
and expecting us to do something on it
so i i'm just asking everybody to
understand that it's not a it's not a
partisan issue there are people who have
partisan perspectives on it but in terms
of representing constituents
you know it's cross-section it's a it's
a bipartisan effort of people who are
trying to get this over the finish line
so i do think we should spend more time
on it than to just
push to retain
so
representative harrington is recognized
yeah just so people are clear and we
don't waste time on it this bill will
not go on consent
[Music]
okay
uh representative thomas is recognized
thank you mr chair um
although i agree with the sentiment uh
being centered about this bill uh
i am hearing the same sentiment for the
third time i want to call the question
please
okay representative
thomas calls the question
in case we need to excuse me mr chairman
just because a member thinks they hear
the same argument there's no no reason
to cut off debate i could have could
update long ago when i heard some
arguments that were made twice
i don't think that's a reason to cut off
any debate just because somebody says
i've heard this before i've heard a lot
of things from the other side before and
i don't call them all the time because i
let them speak i think you should give
us the same courtesy mr chairman
thank you representative sanchez even
though i didn't call on you to speak
representative thomas has made a motion
and it is a legal and legitimate motion
so we have to
representative platt has seconded the
motion that we call the question
representative
you have a parliament i have a question
my hand is up
is it a debatable motion
moving the question no i don't believe
it is
is it i i know that
and so if it's not debatable
then we're in a real
hole
and if it is debatable
then we need to be able to debate it so
i need to know definitively is it a
debatable motion i'm not sure
well we can call the clerk but i'm not
going to the table
uh representing honor is trying to get
any of anything
i think i have a point of order mr chair
representative oxendine what's your
point of order i was the only person
with a hand up at the time that the
cutting off of debate occurred and i
think i could make my point in less time
than it will take for us to hear from
well while we're waiting to get
an answer from the clerk i'll allow you
to speak go ahead
thank you very much sir i i i'm
speaking to the point that was raised by
representative mcgee uh for the first
time which was about the fact that we're
prioritizing
the efficiency i should i i guess i
should say of of debate on the session
four
this is our job this is why we were sent
here if it takes us an extra day if it
takes us all night we're supposed to
debate we're supposed to be thorough and
i think that this whole notion of
cutting things off so it can be rammed
through and no debates does a disservice
to our constituents and to us as
legislators thank you
thank you representative thomas is
recognized no not i didn't lower my hand
sorry oh i'm sorry
recogni
uh representative sausage is recognized
thank you mr chairman uh i really think
that they're uh
in con i don't i hate to contradict uh
representative harrington because he's
usually right
but i think there's a possibility to
have this on consent
if we find some common ground here as
representative uh kelly pitts mentioned
i think it's possible to do that and
incidentally if we can find some common
ground on this i am assured that uh on
the floor we won't have that much debate
on it because we'll have a very strong
vote in favor of something
and as was mentioned this is about
municipalities and towns who are ready
to do something take action
all they are is waiting for some
guidelines this is a republican bill
we're willing to support it we're
willing to compromise on it and just as
a point of information
about the hydro facilities in nashua
they have two facilities one has a one
megawatt capability the other one has a
three megawatt capability maybe we can
find some way of finding middle ground
here so i would encourage us to consider
those amendments and see if we can't
thank you representatives
at the clerk
and
it appears that a motion to call the
question is not allowed in a committee
session
so we can continue to discuss this issue
and then we will vote once we have
exhausted our ability to discuss it
so is there any further question or any
further debate rather on the question of
see okay representative pimentel you're
recognized
uh
thank you mr chairman
uh i i would hope that maybe this motion
to retain could be
an octopass
and then
we can discuss it further
and
uh if
octopass doesn't come
it fails then we can uh look at some of
okay thank you uh representative
representative callie pitts is
recognized my my question would be if
if this is our
and i think it's pertinent
our last session
among ourselves
it would seem that we have
time
or
left because we have dates that we can
we can still meet
when it would it be impossible to get
the sponsor
and the stakeholders again as we have
done before it's tedious it's long it's
but we can do it
and we can do it in a timely manner if
anything was controversial it was 3 15.
and look what happened look what we did
and i think we can we can at least give
it an effort
to do it again without holding this up
again for a year and possibly 18 months
nobody knows what's going to happen with
colbit over the summer we don't they can
talk all they want but they've been
wrong before
so
i think that
that effort might be worth it even if
it's a one-shot deal
uh rather than just saying okay we're
gonna put this off for a year and a half
and we'll see what happens i
i really believe that and i think
retaining
is the wrong thing and i have more faith
in this committee
then i think a lot of people have
because i know we've come up with very
complicated
decisions before on much more
complicated issues
was it easy now did we all like
everything no but we came with a
compromise and i think the sponsor ought
to be uh
involved in this with all of us
not just with
10 of us
with all of us
so that we can talk this over
realistically
and get it through you can still retain
it in in two weeks you could still
retain
uh will it end debate on the flawed no
because something else is going to be
debated
when i left the uh session last week i
was so upset that i drove through lowell
massachusetts
because
we debated something that to me was
ridiculous
printing amendments
let's debate something that's
meaningful and mean something to people
right now
with all the facts on the table
i don't think pushing this off is gonna
work or i think i don't think it's gonna
be any better
in the next year if we can't do it now
we won't be able to do it next year
either
yes my case and
plea for uh compromise i i really
appreciate it uh
representative kelly pitts
i wonder if
members of this committee
would change their mind about this
retained motion
if they learned that there are members
of this committee who refuse
who will refuse to accept an expansion
of net metering
no matter what it looks like
that
they believe that net metering is
not good public policy
therefore they won't move forward
if you knew that
would it change your mind about
retaining this bill in order to avoid
what would turn out to be a floor fight
over this bill
that's a question i put to the committee
does anybody want to answer that
in danger of repeating myself i i think
there's no reason we should be afraid of
a floor fight
and that that's not how the legislature
works that's not our responsibility our
responsibility is to put forward the
best possible policy and i'm sorry that
there are individuals on this committee
who have the wrong-headed notion that
net metering is somehow not good public
policy it's been used uh throughout the
country for over decades has made for a
substantial expansion of renewable
energy and moving us forward into the
clean carbon
uh representative oxygen i'm going to
have to take a sec some sick
exception
it's hard to get out
to your characterization that uh
someone's opinion about
net metering is wrong-headed
i urge you to choose different language
oh my goodness that was so so soft i i
can't imagine anyone
um i i will leave the adjective aside
some people are opposed to net metering
i as a as a policy
and i
don't know i believe i might have been
muted after i said that my point was
that net metering has been used
successfully across the country for
decades as a way of advancing us towards
the clean energy future we all i hope
really don't we all recognize as des
told us on friday this is coming
electrification is coming we are
removing fossil fuels for our health
because it's it's resulting in premature
deaths because it's not it endangers a
stable climate on the planet
we need to be moving forward and not
stuck in old ideological ruts
i i ask you
we have manchester with plans to go
forward lebanon with plans to go forward
concord basketball and across the state
these are jobs this is positive action
for our constituents please let us go
representative all of those projects
that you just mentioned can move forward
without net metering representative
murder is recognized yes um we have this
one grande bill last year that almost
passed um but we had
almost an identical bill to this bill
last year
and the representatives who were there
motioned to table this bill they killed
it we had a compromise with the governor
and with we didn't have everybody on
board with in our caucus we surely don't
we still don't have everybody but we had
a good bill and the motion was made by
table by
then and it's funny that former uh
leader that called me a couple weeks ago
to talk to me
and he said one of the biggest mistakes
we made with net metering last year was
was tabling with the republican bill
last year and he admitted that was his
biggest mistake in the committee last
year so we've already kicked the can
down the road a year let's get it right
uh obviously
there's a lot of questions uh i did
support the bill
last year and it was tabled so
in committee so
uh you can plan on that all we want all
of a sudden there's a big urgency now
they they're the ones that tabled this
bill last year and i'll just leave it at
that
thank you mr chairman
um
i think we could we could pass a bill
out of this committee whether it's the
one that we're dealing with or an
amendment i think we could pass a bill
out of committee
so i think we should
give that a chance
uh vote no on retaining and
representative mann you're recognized
yes thank you mr chairman i'm i'm old
and i'm tired
and i'm lazy but i'm looking forward to
doing a lot of work on this bill because
i think it's something that'll be very
exciting to get done
and i think we'd be proud of ourselves
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative representative
don't forget that on you
muted
representative mick williams you're
uh are you giving me hand signals
nice
you can't you can't figure out how to
i really wanted to hear what you had to
say but
uh representative mcgee
thank you mr chair
um maybe i can pick up some of what
rebecca's trying to say um i mentioned
when i spoke before that there are three
pending amendments that have been put in
on the bill
and to speak to the history from um in
the last biennium
there was a bill 1218 that was for
raising the full net metering cap and it
was basically similar language to hb 167
which we retained earlier today so that
was the whole enchilada right that was
up to five megawatts
and yes the folks that were in
leadership us you know committees last
time that's what we wanted so that was
the reason that representatives lange's
bill in the last session didn't make it
through is because if that was passed
then there would be very there would be
no chance that the larger bill would
make it
so this time we have an amendment for
two megawatts an amendment for three
megawatts and an amendment for five
megawatts
and i think what we need to do
uh i think what everybody is asking for
that's been speaking and which i agree
with is that we have to have the debate
amongst ourselves around
what should we do
because there may be people who always
think we shouldn't do anything and
that's fine but that's not all of us and
so
this idea of compromise that uh
representative kelly pitts brought up
i'm in full agreement with because we
keep going around and around knowing we
have to do something the question is
what are we going to do
and so we probably need further
conversation to figure out which one of
the three amendments is the right
amendment for now
but once we have some consensus around
which one we would be willing to put
forward
i think we would do a floor fight and
let you know let the full house decide
and it is an issue that's been pending a
long time i think for our committee to
not come out with anything with all of
the history that's gone before i mean
representative lang and i we both we
co-sponsored that bill 106 because
you know we want something done and um
so i i really hope that we don't
abdicate the responsibility that we have
by pushing it to retain because that
just does nothing and people have been
thank you that's all
i agree with you that
that we could have a debate about the
three amendments
i'm not sure that that would change our
position on retain because we can have
that debate
retain the bill
and if we retain the bill we avoid
adding to the
length of a house session that we'll be
having later this session
later this
month
or early next month
so
i'm going to propose a compromise right
here i'm going to propose that we take a
lunch break from 12 to 1
and
debate the three amendments
that you mentioned
however before we do that i would like
to vote on the motion to retain
house bill
uh 106.
so
that would be my compromise for now uh
representative nick williams can you
speak now can you
go ahead
okay great um thank you very much chair
bose um my recommendation is if we could
get in touch with um
the office of strategic initiatives i
think it would be really helpful to have
someone um just weigh in on the
governor's stance on 106.
which i think would be a good faith
effort to coming up with a compromise
i would request that we do that for
before we take a vote on retain so my
take back the retain motion and not vote
on that and instead um just treat it
like a work session right after lunch
and get some feedback i think that would
be probably the fair way to move forward
thank you
thank you representative mick williams
glad you figured out how to get back on
okay so seeing no further discussion i'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
on the motion to retain which is a
motion that's on
the floor and has to be dealt with
so mr clerk please call the
representative
yes representative harry
yes
representative clinton
representative
yes
[Music]
yes representative white
yes
no
representatives
representative vincent
i protest this is not in good faith but
i say no
vote of 11 to 10 hb 106 is retained
and
we can start a discussion of the three
amendments proposed for it
at one of
lunch so i look forward to seeing you
all again can i ask i'm confused if it's
being retained why are we discussing
amendments that's not moving anywhere
representative creation you were not
recognized representative callie fitz
you're recognized
i i think that
again i i don't understand what the um
what we would go over the amendments for
because there's no point in doing it now
because we can't unretain it
but the bill is still in committee so i
don't know if we can change the vote
there's another
parliamentary
question because it hasn't gone to the
clerk yet so if discussing these
amendments
um
is valid so that if there's a
possibility of pulling
the bill back and changing the vote
that would be acceptable but if once we
retain it and
because it's still in the house can we
do some still in committee can we do
something it has not been released from
committee yet
and i would also like to ask
representative vos
was i correct in that we are doing
nothing for the next three weeks is that
in our committee not
but in the committee are we doing
nothing for the next three weeks
is that correct
uh not really
we were told this morning that senate
bills will start coming our way
so we probably will have other sessions
before the end of march to deal with
senate bills
uh i don't know how many there will be i
don't know how old they will be
but
you have to keep in mind and i realized
that
because
i'm the chair of the committee and and
doug thomas is vice chair we are
dealing with this every day and you guys
and i i understand that
but
we have to deal with room availability
we have to deal with the fact that the
house only owns five zoom licenses
and so there's a limit to the number of
meetings that we can have on a given day
so there are scheduling constraints that
we have to deal with
that make it difficult for us to just
say okay let's get together and have a
chat you know let's let's get together
as a committee and and have a work
session
if i can follow up i thought we had
mondays
and fridays which i don't like because i
don't like short weekends but i thought
that those were our assigned days and
that we could
utilize them
uh how
however the chairman saw fit fit
that may not be solved
that is correct that is not so monday is
our assigned date
and fridays are occasionally available
if another committee doesn't need
uh
that is assigned to friday doesn't need
that day
so we have been allowed to do some
fridays but it doesn't mean that all
fridays are available
can we find out somehow if this bill can
be
somehow what you said about it's not
going to be changed and nobody's mine is
going to be changed and it won't change
this year and probably won't change next
year because we'll all be the same
people
but
if something could still be done to this
bill since it has not left the committee
yet
so could we change the retain
yes something could still be done with
this bill
uh
if we
vote to reconsider the retain motion and
overturn the retainment
and we can do that we could do something
with this bill before
april 1st which is our deadline
i'm not sure that
a motion to
reconsider the retaining motion would be
successful but we could try
thank you what i suggest we do is after
one o'clock we all come back and talk
about the three amendments
and if we can
arrive at some kind of consensus about
what we could do
to try to achieve a compromise then
maybe at that point a motion to
reconsider the retaining
motion might be in order
if we talk about this for a couple of
hours and we determine hey there's no
compromise we can we can live with here
then there won't be any point in
reconsidering the retaining motion
so
let's all go have some lunch
maybe have a glass of wine with lunch
and be ready to discuss
the three amendments and see if we can
find some kind of weight compromise
so i'll see you all
one o'clock
and i thank you for your hard work this
morning
thank you
caucus
hello
i didn't hear that leak
i just wondered if we could have a
democratic caucus dirk why not
why not we can close out of this and why
i'll send a zoom thank you cat
what are you playing lucius
you should unmute so we can have some
music
i don't know i've been playing the blues
playing peter paul and mary that
stumbled across that repeater paul and
mary
interviewed
[Music]
so
more more
now we know what's missing in our
committee meetings music
[Music]
i was in a band we used to close our
that one oh he knows it
[Music]
exactly exactly
yep
you don't know this one do you
let's see
i can't remember it
yes we can
well it is 100
2 so we can uh
get back together here and have some
we have three potential amendments for
hb 106 that we could discuss we could
discuss them
individually or we could just discuss i
think they all basically do the same
thing
so we can just discuss the concept
that they
address what's your final does anybody
have a
suggestion
representative pementel
um maybe a straw poll just to find out
who's willing to
make a vote other than retain
just a straw poll nothing
that uh counts for anything other than
trying to get the discussion moving
well i personally couldn't
make a decision about whether i would
reconsider unless we had a compromise
position
so
we need to see if we can come up with a
compromised position first and talk
about whether we
would uh
do a straw hole or even in fact do a
vote to be considered although
i see a lot of people missing right now
so i'm not sure
but
uh representatives
um
yes mr chairman uh it seems to me that
the easiest way to approach this would
be to ask for a straw pull up
is anyone willing to raise the cap
higher than one megawatt at this point
if we find majority doesn't want to go
beyond that then
i think most of these amendments would
that's a reasonable suggestion uh
let's do a straw poll to see how many
people here would be willing to
uh mr clerk could you call the role of
the people in the building or in the uh
on the call
in the meeting
news draw a poll i'll write down the
numbers
so
if you are willing to expand the cap
beyond what one megawatt you'll say yes
representative thomas thank you uh i
just made some preliminary comments
uh beforehand
i agree with you
we don't have enough information right
now or is there enough time pass right
now to make a
substantive change
so without more information or more talk
or even a little more time
i don't think anyone's positioned
okay
i'm still in favor of doing a truck stop
hole
um
who can't you hear
i can hear him but i i i can't
understand him
his man's okay
i nearly stated that
not enough time or information is passed
for
i believe an effective straw poll
so
if in doubt or if you don't have more
information
uh for me anyway i
i can't make an honest assessment i
would
so when i'm in doubt i always say no
representative bernardi
i i think there's a distinction on
raising the limit on what the source of
the power is
i would have a different vote on hydro
versus solar or wind
i agree also representative kim burrows
yes i i i was going to say the same
thing representative bernard said
i would vote differently depending on
what what the source is
representative i agree 100 with
representative bernardi
okay so the question uh about raising
the cap above one megawatt is apparently
too simplistic a question
uh representative samsic it looks like
there's a consensus that
it would depend on whether it was
power was uh well i wanted to just
clarify that my motion was to take a
a straw poll on raising
the net metering
one megawatt
uh only for municipalities
not for everybody
so that precludes a lot of projects that
you can't really do
as a municipality so but i i i don't
want to get into the details of what
which areas of net metering
should have individual separate caps i
think
that that is a big discussion and that's
a complicated discussion and not a very
okay representative mcgee
uh thank you mr chair yeah i i was just
gonna say that i i thought
um i i don't care if we take a straw
poll but i feel like
if we don't discuss the amendments we
might not get to any of the
understanding that we'd like people to
have about what is proposed
um
and
if the exception that representative
bernardi made saying that
um
solar net metering cap versus hydro give
him a different you know he has a
different position on whether it should
be raised
then i think it does warrant a
discussion
so i i feel like we're back to
uh
back to looking at the three amendments
that we have in front of us
okay mr chair i'm gonna withdraw my
okay thank you uh and the
request for us for off post withdrawn so
we're back to as representative mcgee
just pointed out
uh maybe discussing the concrete
proposal
there were at least three amendments
i'm sure i have a copy of it here
somewhere
and then i believe representative pitts
proposed an amendment
and
representative mick williams i think
also proposed
so shall we start with yours mr chairman
yes right
found it
basically just put a cap in there that
said
representative
it's an approval over the five that was
but net metering is net metering is
okay
further discussion
thank you mr chairman
so
let's put this this thing to rest once
and for all
about net metering
if you want to have an authoritative
ruling on this the public utilities
commission in 2017
already had a docket
docket order number
26029 on page 69
it states
that there is
little to no evidence of any significant
cost shifting due to net metering
so since that time no new investigation
has been done about this and the one of
the two reasons that this could be the
case is number one because there is no
net there is no shifting of costs
whatsoever and number two is because the
penetration into the electric market by
renewable energy and net metering is so
small that whatever change it might
might result in is not measurable at
this time so right now there is no
evidence that net metering has any cost
shifting okay that is authoritative from
the puc
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative
representative i would just respond that
that was in 2017 when there was highly
in existence since then has grown top
deterred
there's no way the psc would find the
well
representative plett's
assumption point that that was in 2017
there has been a substantial increase in
uh
projects that have been proposed in
maine because maine raised its net
metering cap to five megawatts and they
had so many projects
uh in the queue that they actually had
to stop accepting interconnection
requests
and uh requested and then the puc
requested
that there be a study done
to determine
uh what the effect
of all this i think it was close to 700
more than that i think it was more like
a thousand megawatts of new solar that
was proposed to come online in
in maine what the what the effect of
that was going to be as far as i know
that study is still ongoing but there
have been a plethora of other studies
around the country that have discovered
that there is in fact
a substantial cost shift once you get
beyond a certain penetration movement
and uh
so then the question becomes well
if what is that penetration limit
and uh what should
we do about the potential of cost
shifting
so
i think it's a legitimate question and a
legitimate point and i think it's the
reason why a lot of people
would be uncomfortable
with a
cat
lift all the way to five megawatts
now it's true that in this particular
case because just the case of a
municipal host there's not going to be a
huge
new
penetration of solar
as a result of this bill
but nevertheless
it is
an expansion of
net metering and if there's other
expansions of net metering that go on
we need to have a better understanding
of how that's going to affect
non-net metering
ratepayers before we proceed
uh representative oxendine is recognized
yes thank you um i was not only an
intervener in that proceeding but i was
the one who put in the bill that sent it
to the puc to begin with
yes we've had an authoritative ruling as
an interim measure from the puc that
there is currently and
we've had very little change in the
meager time that has passed since that
report came out
in the meantime synapse has come out
with a study of new england which
demonstrates the far-reaching benefits
of having greater clean energy on the
grid
how it benefits all ratepayers because
it's lowering demand it's lowering peaks
and it's lowering costs to ratepayers
the the notion that we need to be
worried about a situation where we have
a thousand megawatts in the queue it's
being managed
in maine yo they say okay hold up the
queue and we'll work through them one at
a time
we are in the midst of a transition
it's an unprecedented transition but
it's a necessary transition and closing
our eyes and pretending that we're not
in the midst of this transition is doing
a severe disservice to ratepayers and to
taxpayers
if if
manchester and concord and lebanon could
be proceeding with these
plans that are all set to go forward
they could be reducing local property
taxes
this is a measure that needs to go
through and it needs to go through with
no cap up to ferc's involvement at five
okay uh representative kelly pitts
well uh my my i was wondering how do we
know
how it affects new hampshire i'm not
talking about massachusetts i'm not
talking about me if we don't open the
door a little bit new hampshire
we tried to
compromise there
there was a compromise on uh we try to
compromise on how much is allowed one
two three ten whatever
why don't we say
or ask
that within
24 months
the puc opened a current or the buc open
the docket to study
they have one
what what has been going on recently and
what's gone on since
what will go on since we raised the cap
and
put a limit
raise the cap for two years until we get
a definitive nancy from the puc there
are ways around this but there are also
ways
to let
municipalities
go ahead and proceed with projects that
they would like to do
and i'm thinking of the hydro and i'm
thinking of solar which of course takes
up much more
land space or however you do it
we need to come to some sort of a
consensus
about what we can do and then how we can
oversee what's being done and that's
through the puc but maybe we have to in
the initial
legislation asks them
to be the overseer and give us
a report about what what's happening so
we can keep abreast of it
um
and the electric companies certainly
because they have the information on
interconnection requests
so i i think it's a doable i really do
how far you open the door i don't know
but i think
that we need to move ahead on opening
the door rather than doing nothing for
the next year and then saying okay now
we have to crack the door a little bit
i think we have to allow some of these
projects to go ahead
and
what you said this afternoon really
disturbed me this morning it disturbed
me
that
there are people
who i have their heels dug in and i'm
not willing to listen at all
and
i don't know how
we can do that unless we get everybody
together
not just the committee everybody
and discuss what we need to do
um
all the interested parties
include municipalities and not for a
three second sound bite to really work
out and discuss what we need to do
i don't i don't know how
it's like a kid
that's like a child i'm not gonna do it
and i'm never gonna do it and i won't do
it
well
when it comes to that point instead of
beating the core out of the child you
you thought let's talk about this why
won't you do it
what's your motivation why why won't you
do it and very often not always but very
often you'll get more
you just don't want to well but that's
not good enough and you can turn
something around
with the proper discussion but if you
don't have the discussion it's not going
okay thank you
thank you mr chair um just building on
to the previous discussion of the sort
of net effects of of net metering um i
feel like the
you know we're concerned about cost
shifting onto the the rate payer um from
my perspective what we're doing right
now is cost shifting away from
potential generation that could be there
we're just sitting here with our thumb
on the scale saying no you can't produce
power here we're not gonna let you
compete on this market we're not going
to let you provide
extra
extra energy and
everybody that i talked to you know when
i canvassed two years ago when i first
got elected said they want more local
energy they want clean energy this is
like a number one concern of of my
constituents so um i'm in agreement with
lee that that i think we need to go as
far as as ferc will let us um with this
but
you know if we can compromise
i'm willing to to come back a little bit
from that but but we clearly need to
move on from where we are now thank you
thank you i'd just like to clarify one
thing that you said um
you implied that if we don't raise the
cap on net metering that people can't
build anything larger than one megawatt
that's not true
you can build
as large a system as you want
today it has nothing to do with the net
metering cap
fidelity investments over in merrimack
built a 3.1 megawatt solar farm on their
property
and they use the electricity from that
farm to offset 20 percent of the
electricity that their campus uses
so there's nothing that prevents a
company or an individual or a city or
town
building a solar system
of two three four
up to five megawatts
the only thing that net metering does is
it provides a little some additional
revenue
to the individual
owner of that
solar system or that uh alternative
renewable energy system to earn a little
bit more money
may i follow up sorry
but so that that power just goes back
for free
into the grid correct if there's not net
metering
depends uh if you want to put power back
on the grid and you contact the utility
and ask the utility to give you a credit
for it
they probably will
but the credit they'll offer you is
probably closer to the wholesale price
than the
prices that the net readering
statute currently offers
for those net metering credits
another thing that i would point out
with regard to a comment that
jackie califitz made
there is an ongoing docket at the pnc
about the net meter and tariff it's been
open since
2016.
it's been open for a long time and they
have
started a bunch of different
many studies
to help them arrive at
an overall
decision on what the proper net metering
tariff should be and those studies are
still ongoing and until they're
completed they will come up with a
final and definitive
decision about what that metering should
be
um
why can't renewable
energy compete at wholesale levels
um and what would be so there's
incentives now
for people to set up uh renewable energy
and then that removes the incentive to
try and make it more efficient so that
it can compete at wholesale levels
what would be the incentive
for for it to be more efficient if you
don't have to and you still make money
anybody want to take a stab at that
representation
i mean
may we make it give it an expiration
date then um if that's our concern is
that people aren't working toward it i
mean i think you're you're always going
to be working towards making it better
if that's a concern i you know i'd be
open to working on them
i already had a hand up but
my thought on the wholesale idea in
terms of value
is that
um i mean that is a crucial question
that the public utilities commission and
the folks who price
uh energy
are trying to figure out which is what
is the accurate value for this
additional energy that can be supplied
near the source it does have a value
though and so the idea of saying well we
don't want to open up and allow net
metering because we're afraid
that somebody's gonna
you know make money they shouldn't
um but if they're producing energy that
can be used then it does have a value
and i think this committee is woefully
ill prepared to decide what that value
is there are other people that are doing
that piece of the work but to say that
there is no legitimate value or that you
know i mean i think that's part of the
problem here is we can't figure out
whether it's one two three five because
we're
we're concerned about the value and we
haven't figured out a good way to talk
amongst ourselves about it
i think there's enough evidence out
there that there's significant value to
having local sustainable energy and i
know in my town we've made a bunch of
investments and we would certainly
see a reduction in local property taxes
if we were able to recover the renewable
energy credits between the one megawatt
that we're capped at now and uh you know
four or five wherever it is that um all
of our
plant together would come to if we had
if we were able to take each of the one
megawatt uh two mega well two megawatt
um
installations that we have and net meter
them then that would just bring the cost
down for everybody because it would go
off of the municipal electricity bill
that all of us contribute to so there's
a lot of different ways to look at the
money piece of this we haven't had any
of those discussions so right now people
just think what they think
we didn't bother to get answers to those
questions which is something we could do
if we had had more work groups on that
but i think to just dismiss it out of
hand and say well renewables different
so it doesn't you know shouldn't be
default should be wholesale why isn't it
wholesale wholesale
prices are lower because the people who
generated wholesale generate a lot
right so if you're under five megawatts
you don't qualify for wholesale that's
why that's an answer
but there's other answers too because
it's complicated so
i would say there is a value to this
energy
and us not even getting into the
place where we're able to look at it and
have data from it in our own state
prevents us from being able to have the
analysis that we need to say how much is
the right penetration point where we
would cut it off because we're we're
just nowhere near that we really we
haven't run any experiment yet we're a
pilot
follow-up representative griffin yes uh
thank you uh representative mcgee for
your response
um you mentioned that this committee
can't uh you know doesn't have the
resources to determine the appropriate
value i would argue that no committee
can determine the appropriate value that
we are not a command economy and that
the free market should determine the
value and then
pay more or not on their own thank you
can i just
yeah i mean i i have no problem with the
free market being involved but the fact
is there's a very sophisticated
tariff system because there are so many
different
variables that are being taken into
consideration when pricing happens in
the energy market so
what i'm saying is we don't have
expertise in setting those pricings on
this committee i i think our committee
has the responsibility and the
capability and the wherewithal to get
that information and to get more answers
if we ask the right questions i i don't
think we've been given the time to do
that
don't you think uh representative mcgee
and i don't want a quest to want an
answer from you but
don't you think it's reasonable for this
committee to
make a judgment
that it is not good policy
for one set of rate payers to have to
subsidize another secretary affairs and
i think that's what's at the base of
this question representative
90 years ago we established the women's
state's a wholesale electricity market
uh nepo stated uh it's running this
system to a new entity called iceland
new england and nice and normal reports
to nepal but isolation has been trying
to do that but ever since we did that
instead of a wholesale market we've been
under money we've been undermining it by
net metering and by subsidies here and
somebody's there wrecks and uh best reps
and all these subsidies undermining the
market and part of the reason
electricity is so cheap now is because
the market being undercut
and we're having this stuff come up it's
not
controlled by isil new england at all
itself
as a price taker
and it gets subsidized if the market's
not on your last mistake it's going to
uh representative oxendine you're
recognized thank you very much um as the
chair mentioned the pucs proceeding on
on this issue is ongoing we are about to
get the um the rfp has been put out for
a value of solar study here in new
hampshire
we should be allowing that proceeding to
go forward but
certainly recognizing at the moment
there is no unsubsidized energy market
billions of dollars in subsidies of oil
and gas have been going on for decades
renewable energy has been incentivized
we we have a very complex market and
that's why we have experts who do the
rate setting our job is to do policy
setting not to get down into the
nitty-gritty of the wholesale market and
which parts are are in there but we do
have a very recent study put out which
looks at the value of solar in our
regional market and tells us at a
minimum it's worth 12 cents per kilowatt
hour whereas the wholesale rate is at
2.5 or 3 cents per kilowatt hour
this is a a a number that is in line
with the puc's finding of no significant
cost shifting this is a number we can
work with and many of many of our towns
and cities are prepared to go forward
with
in a way that can help ratepayers and
help taxpayers we need to be assisting
those municipalities
and our ratepayers and taxpayers in
moving ahead we have sufficient
information and we're going to get more
thank you i think most economists would
tell you that something is worth what
people are willing to pay for it
we have monopoly i'm sorry
what we're debating here is what we
think people will be willing to pay for
representative pimentel is recognized
thank you mr chairman first of all this
is not a
free market as far as energy it's a
regulated market
so
um you know we have the puc and to
determine
those rates
but also i wanted to bring up
the fact that what we're talking about
is a very limited bill
which is
dealing with municipalities
and county government
and i suppose i have no idea if state
government would be included in this or
not i probably
but it
at any rate
um
you're talking about cost shifting from
rate payers
and if if you were talking about
municipality and county government
we are
all part of we are all citizens of our
own towns our own counties and so
if there is any rate shifting here it's
shifting it from us to us
so
as
as a
pilot project and that's what this is
really there's a pilot project it's a
pretty safe one
and i think it's
worth
uh opening the doors a little bit
um
and
let's seeing what will happen
in the market
when we do that
this is a risk well worth taking it's
going to increase our renewable
portfolio which is a good thing for
everybody
and um
that's what i think thank you
thank you i'd react to that by saying
it's not just a transfer from us to us
it's a transfer from the taxpayers of
one town to
the ratepayers of all other towns
sorry i think my hand was held up in
error
i think it was just up from previously i
apologize representative callie bits
well
if the if the discussion as you
as was proposed before was about
subsidies we subsidize everything in
every way
then the state shouldn't be paying
anything we subsidize companies to come
in through different benefits and we
subsidize schools because local towns
just can't do it right
so if we call it a subsidy we can call
it assistance we want to call it help we
want to give it a different name
this is not a subsidy
we are trying nobody is getting rich on
this
nobody
towns and municipalities are not going
to risk
the money from their citizens because
they all want to get reelected so
they're going to have to come up with a
pretty
concrete plan of what this is going to
do
and how it's going to do it
and i think that you know stopping them
from making that decision
is totally unconscionable we have to
allow something and the fact that a
docket has been open in the puc
since
is also unconscionable who's subsidizing
the puc every single one of us because
it's funded by the electric companies
so
five years to study something if you had
in private sector five years to study
something by the time you finish
studying it's out of date you gotta
study it again
i i think that we need to
get moving and then we need to
get some concrete evidence about what is
the effect of new hampshire
we don't even know if the town of
lebanon will go through with something
once it hears all the parameters we
don't know
so i i think we really have to look at
that
and allow
concrete evidence to come in nobody
nobody
and we don't want to cut out
the people this will help the people who
can't put up
solar arrays who don't have a river
running in the backyard that they can
tap
we're not helping just
the cities the big cities and towns
helping the people in those cities and
towns and i think that's what we have
about
we can put all kinds of limits on this
stuff
but we need to help the people right now
and we need to help them with jobs and
getting out of a jam
so i i don't know why we want to call it
subsidizing
if somebody could get rich doing it you
better believe or i better believe that
it would have been done
thank you mr chairman i i was just going
to piggyback on the idea of
the the portfolio because i think that's
another consideration that we haven't
really talked about as a committee
i know when i started paying attention
to new hampshire energy
it was a big concept that portfolio
diversity was something that the policy
makers at the state level and in the
then office of energy planning were very
concerned with the fact that we didn't
want to have a monopoly of any one
particular fuel type that we wanted to
make sure that we maintained diversity
and basically managed the pieces of the
portfolio so if you wanted to clean up
you know the
the the power plants which we have done
right the coal and oil plants have been
really minimized and and uh translated
over to gas and in some cases but
basically the idea is that that was
one way that people who were doing
policy could look at what the makeup was
in new hampshire and decide what changes
they were going to make
the renewable
portion of the portfolio has been
maintained at under one percent it's
very minuscule
and we have been fighting ourselves for
quite a while trying to figure out how
we broaden that so that we can give
that competition
uh maintain diversity
and also increase the sectors that
contribute to clean
power
and so there's a number of drivers for
it that provide it with value to the
state that is not just
whatever's being
paid to people to credit them for the
value of the energy that they're
producing
but
you can't get something for nothing
right and so the idea that well they can
in they can invest in it even if they
don't get anything back for it that's
true but most people will invest based
on the return of investment and a lot of
people have been dissuaded from
investing in clean energy for themselves
or in their towns because of this very
thing because we're not making it an
economic decision that works for people
and so
um
my argument would be
that because we're not looking at the
things that many of the people who come
and testify before us they give us these
examples they give us concrete evidence
of of the benefits um that there will be
to towns to states and to local property
taxes which to me
that's a really big charge no matter
what party you are that's what we that's
one of the reasons that we're trying to
get more support for renewable local
sustainable energy is because
it's the only mechanism that we have at
our disposal i think to actually help
lower
uh what people are paying and so that
would be my argument is that we're not
giving enough
there's a reason why people are trying
to do renewables there's a reason behind
all of it and just trying to hold back
that dam of all the people that are all
the pent up projects
um
it's it is doing a disservice
it is doing a disservice it's it's us
standing in the way of
of
an economic
um
i don't want to say boom because i don't
think it would be that much but there's
certainly a lot of pent-up demand and
um
i don't i haven't heard any arguments
that are adequate
to holding back that demand i think that
we work for the people and to jackie's
point the people have been asking us for
this for years
uh because they're trying to get on with
what they're doing in order to lower
their expenses at the town level and
uh we can help them or we can hurt them
and right now we're not doing anything
to help
so should we get back to the
bills uh like to the the the
the amount i mean the amendments the
levels of the amendments can we
can we bring the talk back to
y
y one y two y three by
because
there have to be reasons
peter
you knew that i i was glad to hear you
echoed the comments of the mayor of
lebanon last year
that
everybody wants solar but nobody wants
to pay for it
did i say that i don't remember saying
that
this discussion but yes we can get back
to uh discussing a specific bill
or a specific amendment
sure um
representative
yes
at the risk of sounding childish in some
people's views
i just don't think that
increasing subsidies is a good thing and
so we're wasting your time here
discussing megawatt levels i don't want
metering at all
i just think it's it's a rate payer
ripoff
to subsidize certain entities over other
publications period
okay representative samson you wanted to
chime in
uh
yes mr chairman i i i noticed you a very
cleverly said let's let's discuss your
amendment first but i'd like to see you
okay i'll do that as soon as i hear from
representative creation
thank you mr chair um going back a bit
to lee's point about the fact that we
subsidize literally everything i feel
thinking about in the future all the
cleanup that we are going to need to do
over fossil fuels all of the investment
that we have to make in doing these
things what
taking care of these externalities what
is that if not continuing to subsidize
um
you know through
government investment and and through
all these things that we need to do and
through diminished quality of life for
our kids subsidizing a very small number
of people who um
you know who are investing in this thing
so i i think just looking at
this one policy
in isolation we really need to see the
the bigger picture of where we need to
move to and stop subsidizing things that
we're going to have to pay for even more
down the line
okay thank you
so representative samsung
follow up on your request that i justify
my amendment because you'll recall
or maybe you weren't here i don't
remember
when i introduced this amendment i
introduced it as a way to stimulate
discussion to see if there was any way
we could come to some kind of a
compromise on
this issue
and
i put together this amendment just as a
way to
generate that discussion i was
particularly interested at the time
we could do something that wouldn't
generate a significant floor
and it became clear to me after our
discussion
was it last friday i think it was last
friday
that that wasn't going to happen
so
that was why
this morning i didn't
reintroduce this amendment because it
had
my judgment done what i
set out to achieve which is
to discover if there was any possibility
of a way we could we could uh arrive at
some kind of consensus and last friday
there was no consensus and so
to me that meant that
we weren't going to get anywhere with
this event
so that was justification for for
submitting this amendment well you
certainly have stimulated discussion
with that that succeeded
that is true we have simulated the
discussions stimulated
well so then we should move on to the
other amendments that are out there sure
i'm happy to discuss the other
amendments
uh let's see one was from representative
callie pitts uh
representative callie pitts you want to
discuss your amendment
yeah being very very very discouraged
about not wanting to talk and not
wanting to compromise and going from one
two three
i think i made the comment to
representative mckee did we take a dart
board and decide what it should be one
two three four five ten whatever
and i thought well let me do some simple
first grade math
take five divide it in half and round up
and come out with three
and
i don't think that that's a
overly
exaggerated amount i think that's amount
that it's workable i think that's an
amount that is probably workable for
nashua so that they can get some
use out of their news and falls
i think that
we
need to really open up the discussion i
don't think any one of us
including
those of us who supported five in the
past or whatever know what is a proper
number we just know we don't want it to
run them up
we don't want it to get out of hand and
we want the puc to oversee it and i
think that just simply changing
the
the megawatts so that we actually get a
project that may be meaningful
that we could really study
and see what the effects are
and that was my motivation and that's
all
nothing nothing sinister
nothing in the background but i think
i received an email
from
cleaning adventures
on
the
amendment that i submitted last friday
on
hb 106
and
she was concerned that the two megawatt
limit would exclude small hydro projects
that are currently between two and five
megawatts right
that was concerned she had
[Music]
she also was concerned about a couple of
solar projects
that were less than or greater than
watts like concord gary manchester king
dover franklin and salem
just to name a few
she had a concern about making it
within a municipality
so those were concerns that she had she
also pointed out that there is a similar
senate bill 109
so she said at this point we would
prefer that hb 106 be retained
rather than passed with the proposed 2
so i just thought i would i would pass
along those
concerns that she had
to add to the
discussion
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
and that brings a good point to the
amendment that we're looking at now from
representative cali pitts which is that
three would be more acceptable than two
because there are
existing facilities who would be
borrowed from net metering
um based on their status of being over
two and i very poorly tried to describe
that in our work session and didn't get
it out there but i guess if you're
if you're if your production capacity is
above the two
meter cap then you're not able to
net meter for a percentage of what you
generate uh so you it has to be
the net metering cap has to be above
your generation capability so
it it it is good that clean energy new
hampshire at least has the details of
the landscape that they can provide you
or provide us to let us know that there
are actual facilities out there that are
going to be affected by this and that
would be an argument to say
this is a pilot right if it's
municipalities not everybody it's not
opening up net metering for everybody
who wants it it's just
municipalities
uh who have it already invested
basically i mean there may be some that
decide to invest or have projects
pending that they would like to invest
in but uh it's gonna
it's gonna
increase the margin of their
return on investment
and allow them to give immediate savings
back to their ratepayers because it's
going to lower the cost of the energy
that they use to run their buildings
their municipal buildings and schools or
whatever whatever's part of their
um
facility
so
that's that's my understanding and my
reason for supporting the idea of
getting something through this year i
think it would be uh
it would be a huge
improvement that
many people would give us credit for and
and
my understanding is i mean hb 106 was
1402 last time it was a bill that the
governor asked for at up to five
so
us putting it through i think the house
there are people in the house who won't
want net metering no matter what just
like there's people on the committee
that just feel that way
but i think
the house also looks to us to give them
you know to give them the reasoning of
whether it's good or not and why and i
think we can make the argument that a
three megawatt cap is extremely
reasonable and
and also this is a very limited bill to
to representative pimentel's um original
point
which is that it's it's not opening up
net metering for anybody that wants it
it's just saying municipalities that are
investing here
you can
save money now
and that's what they want to do and
that's what we should be trying to help
them to do
i i'm sure my town would be thrilled if
they could save some more money and uh
and show people that the investments
that their energy committee
incited them to make
are actually going to pay off some more
for all of us
so that's how i look at it and um you
raised an interesting point
representative
[Music]
thank you
that point being
[Music]
municipalities are interested in
my question would be
what is holding them back because if
they built a
three megawatt solar system then that's
three megawatts of electricity they
don't have to buy from their utility so
that would save money
my guess is that what holds them back is
the acquisition costs of buying
one of these systems
so
would you be open
do you think many people would be open
to the
idea of
a cap in the bill
that says that
once your acquisition costs
are
uh capitalized once you've bought your
solar system then your
you would no longer be allowed to net
meter your excess energy well wouldn't
you still be contributing
so now you just enjoy energy
the uh yeah doing the whole rate and
just enjoy the fact that you don't have
to buy the electricity anymore but
you've paid for your system with that
i i understand what you're saying you're
saying once your return on investment is
recaptured then maybe you shouldn't be
getting any credit anymore but you would
still be delivering energy that would
lower the load for everybody and lower
the amount of fuels from outside the
state that would need to be imported so
if
if more municipalities were producing
energy that's locally sourced and
creating local jobs and blah blah you
know it would it would lower overall
cost because the amount of fuel that
would need to be imported would go down
you know like
the costs overall would because once
you've made that investment you don't
have future investments for another 20
25 years so
um
it would be
a savings once you've made that recoup
so i mean it's something that could be
looked at but i don't think we're
prepared to put that in this bill like i
don't think we understand the
implications of having a cap that says
you know
you no longer can make money for the
energy that you're producing once you've
made back the investment that you paid
out to put it in place because i know in
the case of my town my town already made
their investments so i don't know how
far along they are on the continuum of
recouping
but the investments that they made but i
know that they are concerned that they
uh don't have the ability to net meter
to a sufficient level that they
can
uh lower the costs where they thought
they would be able to because they
understand that generating that
electricity actually has a value that
they should be able to recover
well most towns if they put in a three
megawatt solar facility
it would cost three million dollars to
build the facility and i don't think
most towns could afford to pay for that
without bonding over 20 or maybe even 30
years
so the
acquisition cost for such a system would
be
dragged out or spread out over a fairly
long period of time
the other issue is you put up a 3 milli
megawatt solar system you're going to
need at least 15 maybe 20 acres of land
and
then you have to go through the planning
the sighting process
and as a member of a planning board in
my town i know that
citing that development of any kind is
zoning regulatory barriers that you have
to hurdle
and then you have a butter issues and
they can be very
so acquisition
the
project like that can be very very
involved
and
i agree i i'm on the zoning board in my
town and i understand that all of those
issues play in um
but i i think we have examples and
madeline tried to give you some of them
that people are already investing and
trying to move forward so
it's a question of whether we're helping
them or hindering them
that's
we're the only ones that can help in
terms of giving them a stable
environment in terms of the policy that
they can understand if we keep you know
changing it and throwing it up in the
air it's really hard for them to
understand what they should be doing
they think they're doing what they
should be doing but they're waiting for
signals from us as well i think that's
how i look at it from the people i've
alright the risk of you and i getting
into one debate
offline i'm going to ask representative
mick williams to weigh in with her
opinion
try to unmute if you can
hear me
yes i can hear you now
excellent um
i i want to point out that i represent
uh the west side of concord and the city
reducing our electric supply to
non-carbon sources which means the city
is looking right now to put in a very
large solar array um they have the land
they're ready to go but this bill would
make a huge amount of difference
in terms of incentivizing the
municipality to do it and yes i would
say many times that they could do it
without this bill and they may just do
that
but when we look at what our role is as
state representatives to support our
municipalities and our elected role to
help them not hinder them
i would say that that is the number one
goal of this bill is to help our
municipalities
to enable them to become
free this is a freedom issue where they
can produce their own electricity to
offset their own costs and it's not
about
more for them less for someone else it's
about reducing costs for individual
municipalities so they can spend the
money elsewhere
so yes the puc is still working on
coming up with a number for what is
appropriate for our economy in new
hampshire for a number of uh net
metering whether it's five or three or
some other number
but at this point we've been debating
this for over four years and i think we
all know that we're not going to come to
a perfect consensus we need to come to
something that can work
so i i am happy to put the time in to
come up with something that can work
i don't want this to just be a one-sided
this is how it's going to be i think
there is a compromise in the middle path
um
i also wanted to note that i did call
the office of strategic initiatives um
and requested that the director join us
i don't see anyone in the guest list
who's identified themselves as a member
of osi um so that's a little
disappointing but
certainly i would like to hear from osi
to understand where we can find a middle
path to move forward because i have the
city of concord counting on me to do
everything i can do to help my
municipality and i'm not the only person
who was elected to help their
municipality find a way to save money i
think we're in a really difficult
position where
following the pandemic
municipalities are scrambling to come up
with revenue streams and sources of
money
we're really in a tough spot where we're
feeling the pinch financially and this
is the sort of bill that can really help
a lot of cities and towns across the
state so i'll leave it there but i
really think we need to look at this
from a global perspective and i do think
there is a middle road here
thank you representative vincent you
look like you have a bad case of cabin
fever and
need to uh vent a little bit
well you've known me from the past i'm
kind of like i like to move around a lot
i don't like this let the grass grow or
moss grow underneath my feet however i
just wanted to comment that um
and thank you mr chairman thank you i
just wanted to comment about uh taking
up plots of land for solar
uh if you have uh multi multi-uh
buildings multiplex buildings that are
owned by municipalities they're doing
rooftops also and they're also doing uh
like a pod that rotates with the sun
there's a lot of new things that coming
out every single day
um and representative mcgee touched on
some things i'll just leave it at that i
just feel that
um
i don't know i feel that we should
really think about this uh this affects
a lot of people
uh on both sides it really does um and
thank you for letting me speak
absolutely
absolutely representative murder is
recognized yes i've been on board with
uh group membering but i had my
a lot of eyes opened up a lot last year
right after that bill we had 70 proposed
um
five megawatt projects in the state of
new hampshire most on landfills whether
it was dairy
uh i could you know northumberland
whitefield just my district alone and
these companies are in here to make
money at the end of the day because i'm
i'm in the construction trades i
represented them and they ran hard they
unless we gave them that money they
weren't going to do it and no matter
what it's going to be sold at the retail
rate once you give somebody that money
the town's going to say oh
what uh chairman votes brought up is
absolutely awesome in acquisition you
know let it die but these towns are
going to say no we need the money we
need the revenue and ultimately to fred
plett's point the ratepayers are going
to pay it and it's a retail price i know
i pay
i buy my electricity independently right
at seven point
seven cents i get right now i mean
versus eighteen cents
so i mean we gotta you know once you
open up pandora's box we have to think
about this so there's a lot that goes
into this a lot more and dealing with
these companies because i am the head of
economic development for a while in
coahuas county
there is i mean when these companies
just ran but we voted down the bills
last year you know they had a 20 000
piano unit the guy was ready to roll out
and we were fumbling he just left
so
no matter how we slice at the end of the
day and no town can afford this to start
out
you know to
the chairman's point so i mean basically
we're going to subsidize these companies
to build them they make money i have one
company from nebraska another one from
connecticut
uh then i've been looking at all these
projects manchester
derry the ones that i was involved with
so
there is i mean it sounds great and
believe me i agree it sounds great clean
energy and all that you know but 20 000
panels i mean
that's the average one of these projects
so we got to think about it because it
once we start the subsidy we can't go
back
you guys know it's a pilot program well
you're going to say well my town just
invested a million dollars we can't stop
it it's just like these thermals that i
don't want ended but we have many
projects that i wrote grants on for
thermals
they're into these projects now so
what's the number one argument we've had
on 213 was that we had all these people
have all this money invested in it we
can't take them back
and i agree with that so if we give them
these now at these rates we can't take
them back
good points uh representative pimentel
thank you mr uh chairman uh there's a uh
mark sanborn
in in the uh
participants with his hand up we're
mr sandborn uh you are recognized to
introduce yourself
yes uh good afternoon all uh my name is
mark sanborn i'm the new energy advisor
in the office of osi so i just wanted
the the representatives know
uh we are um following the hearing and
we are listening in um i can tell you
that um as of right now we will not be
weighing in
on either this bill or any of the other
bills currently in committee in either
chamber as already noted there's a bill
in the senate that is um has been
offered and so we're going to hold
judgment on any of the bills
until there's final passage they come
out of committee um and we see what the
legislature is moving forward with um so
we're following we're listening um we're
taking notes but
we won't be weighing in
until um
thank you appreciate you uh
introducing yourself and congratulations
representatives well i have a couple and
seeing that i don't know if mark mr
sanborn is still on but i wonder if he's
not weighing in
does he have any pertinent information
that the committee should have
um
that's a possibility you can give
information and facts without
weighing in on a bill
do you want to comment on that request
no i mean i don't think our office has
any additional information
um you know at this point i know this
has been debated heavily in the last
couple of sessions even though that was
before i arrived in this position and so
no we we have no information to add um
we'll wait to see what you guys um
what the legislature moves forward with
um before deciding if it's within the
governor's policy agenda or not
okay i i'd like to just follow up with
uh chairman votes
what chairman votes's proposal
may i
yes
as i suspected that this would then hold
this up for for quite a while and that's
what we're doing the holding this bill
up whether we whatever we do with it
it's going to get held up because it's
going to get held up whether we want to
do it or whether we don't want to do it
or wouldn't it likes it or the governor
likes it to your point
chairman votes about
uh putting uh a time limit on it i think
if we did that i wouldn't be objections
to say once you've recouped
your capital fees and you're not paying
anything which will take
i would think
20 to 30 years
and you go into that
that project with your eyes wide open
and knowing that that's going to be the
case
i wouldn't see a problem with that we
have done that with uh
electric companies
matter of fact and then they're they're
they're done by the puc but we have a
certain little hitch on there that's
called stranded costs which means
they're not going to be on the hook for
anything well we're not offering these
people stranded costs we're offering
them
to recoup their capital costs
and then that's the end of it
and that to me
is not unreasonable
so i myself would not
think that if something like that could
move this bill
along it wouldn't be harmful as long as
the parties know what the agreement is
thank you
representative mcgee
i hate to say it but it might actually
be preferable
because it would be at least
if
other you know future legislators didn't
throw it up and down it would be really
helpful for people who are doing
planning to understand what the deal is
and what you know that they would
uh receive some incentive to be able to
um
switch their chemical plant over so that
they had some local sustainable energy
uh you know i know i got information
from my energy committee um
with some of the bills that we had this
time i asked them
what we had um saved as a result of the
investments that we've made in the
conversions that we've made over time
and the panels on our schools and that
sort of thing and it's over a hundred
thousand dollars a year i mean we're
saving a lot of money because of these
investments so
to your point that there are towns that
don't have the money to invest that is
true
but if you have net metering
more municipalities will consider the
idea of lowering their overall cost by
making some investments and they can
make them over time
but if they understand that
the state will help them with those um
upfront costs
and recouping their capital investment i
think that that that sounds like a very
reasonable policy to me
so um i just think we should do
something on it because the idea that
nothing needs to be done is
it just really feels like we're
i'm sorry more editorializing i'm sorry
representative callie pitching still
have your hand up oh okay i forgot to
okay um representative nick williams are
you still here
[Music]
no it's actually left
i'm here i'm here
can you hear me would you like to
discord discuss uh your amendment
give us your rationale for your
amendment
i think my amendment is the long shot um
because it's the five megawatts instead
of the three that we were talking about
as a compromise so um
the the changes between the original
bill and my amendment are simply
changing uh keeping the five megawatt
and also allowing um communities to
share across borders so it's not just
limited to one municipality
those are the two big things that i
think would make a difference
if we were serious about moving forward
with the big number um but from the
discussion i've heard thus far it sounds
as though five megawatts is probably far
outside the realm of reasonable
compromise and so i don't believe that
this is a realistic amendment and i'm
going to say it's simply here for
discussion um it's probably not the one
we've moved forward with but here we are
can you say more about the other piece
though
about municipalities yeah
because i think that's an important
piece that
the other the others don't have the
other amendments don't have
pull it up so i'm looking at the same
thing as everyone else
political subdivision
yeah it allows i think it's allowing
county um
so a municipal host could be owned by
either public or private entity
i'm looking at uh
line
so this allows
here we go if the facility began
operation after january 1 2020 a
municipal host shall be located in the
same municipality as all group members
or
serve group members located in
contiguous municipalities so an example
here would be um if
i we're we're looking at some solar in
my community of concord
um it's right on the concord bow line
so there is some potential for concord
and bow to do sharing if they determined
that it made sense
um so this would allow that because
they're contiguous right they're
touching one another
so that that opens up um i think more
potential for sharing resources
and i think that's probably
more reasonable from a long-term
perspective because you may have small
towns
that have the ability to share between
two towns for a hydro facility but a
single hydro may be too much for just
thank you uh representative mick
williams i have a question for you about
that
this he has a fairly
extensive experience with
towns and to share
school
and
sometimes it works but in a lot of cases
there's
controversy and there's ugly breakups
when
towns decide to
that they can no longer work together on
a single school
you fear the same thing could happen
host
groups if they were shared amongst towns
that's a great question chair bows i'm
glad you bring that up
the the interesting thing is we do have
um a history of breakups right in the
state of new hampshire we've had towns
come together for schools and then break
up over it and determine how to allocate
funds after the fact so we have some
precedent for divorce
um certainly i wouldn't want that to
happen but it's a potential that it
could happen and we have precedent to
look to and
make similar decisions
following an energy breakup between two
or more municipalities that may have
been pooling resources
i think that there was a really good
discussion a little bit earlier about
bonding a project and how that would
look
how the paperwork would be structured
for coming up with financing to actually
do the initial install
so i would say you would probably look
to the paperwork on the bonding to
determine who's on the hook and at what
percentages
and that's how it would be handled just
like
a actually just like a divorce if we're
looking at dividing assets between
spouses when they divorce
it's the same
situation where we look to the contract
and look to what was agreed upon look to
who was contributing what and who was
taking what from the relationship in
order to do an amicable divorce
so i don't see this as being new or
novel um we certainly have precedent for
breakups
but in the same hand i think that there
are projects here in new hampshire that
could not possibly happen without
contributing municipalities having
multiple towns come together in order to
thank you for that explanation you may
recall that we spent quite a bit of time
in the hb 315 amendment
uh specifying what would happen if
someone opted out of an aggregation and
went back to the vault service for
was on default service and wanted to opt
into the aggregation
and who was responsible for what so it
can be complicated and required
significant amount of
rule making in order to make it happen
representative mcgee can comment on this
possibly when i lived in hollis i lived
there for 15 years and it seemed like
every town meeting there was something
on the warrant
that had to do with a disagreement
between hollis and brookline over the
allocation of costs for their combined i
just want you to know that i actually am
sponsoring and speaking on a bill in
front of education tomorrow on
apportionment
so it has not changed i can tell you
that
all right who uh who else wants to speak
uh on
representative williams version of the
anybody have anything further to say on
this subject i think we've explored it
quite uh
thoroughly in the hour and 15 minutes
one more thing
you have cheers else you'd like to add
oh representative bernardi actually has
something to eat like this so yes just
with respect to hydro power i think
because these are existing
infrastructure
been there a long time there's there's a
potential for utility for uh
municipalities take advantage of those
and i uh and it's a small defined
in place installments that would be
eligible for that
i could
agree to expand net metering
for those kinds of facilities but for
solar or wind power i think that one
megawatt limit is perfectly legitimate
and i
refer to the representative werner said
uh
what we're going to be doing is passing
costs on to late payers in a
undefined exploding rate and i'm not
signing up for that
situation
okay thank you now uh representative
mcgee you have something else to add
yeah i i think it might be moot at this
point but i guess
my only
parting thought would be
if we have any consensus around what it
is we were trying to accomplish with
this bill because
this bill keeps coming back again and
again and again i understand um
representative brazhini
thinks hydro is the only legitimate you
know recipient of of net metering
but um
that's not what we're yeah that's that's
not what the bill is right the bill is
is broader than that but it is just
municipalities so
are we trying to do a pilot are we
trying to solve something for
municipalities are we you know i i wish
we just knew what our objective was
because
without understanding what it is
we may or may not be trying to solve
we
you know we're we're really just uh
all making individual points that don't
really lead to anything and i it's a
concern of mine because
i thought we had heard enough bills even
in the last you know we've been hearing
them for a long time all trying to do
the same thing
this one is more limited than most
but it's not just hydro because that's
not what people are asking us for
so
um
i i just wonder if
if we're ever going to have any
discussion as a committee about what
goals we have around net metering
if there are any goals that we're trying
well none metering all
that's an interesting question
representative flint yeah how about not
i know that representative mcgee is goal
oriented because that's what businesses
do and very often they take their goals
and throw them in the toilet but i think
that what we're trying to do here
is encourage
alternative sources of power
and and utilize the resources some of
which we have and some of summers which
we need to take advantage of such as
hydro that we're not taking full
advantage of such as the sun which god
has given us i think we have to
uh
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to encourage that use
and we're trying to give incentives
which are given every day
in every way
to everybody
you know even the federal government now
has given us incentives and
you know
we have to do
something
to help new hampshire
recover and bringing down electric rates
is one of them and i think that this can
bring down
electric rates and i think that
you know representative vos had a very
good idea i think that there are other
ideas here that you know maybe
contiguous
communities can go into it with each
other
even if they fist fight a little bit
i think that
we need to do that
and to say
nearly just blanketly
we don't subsidize anything it's totally
a false statement i can't name one area
of life that is not subsidized in this
state in one way or another we just
voted i do believe to exempt
municipalities from
paying certain fees well what's that if
it's not a subsidy to win a municipality
because if those fees aren't paid they
got to be collected someplace else so i
think we need to really look at what
we're doing we can put a time limit on
it we can put the cap on it we can have
we can order a review we can tell the pc
review it not for 20 years give us a
report and a review
in in 24 months
we can do all those things
but if we're just plain not willing to
entertain the idea of net metering
i wonder if somebody's going to put a
bill in
to remove
net metering from the individuals who
have it now
it's just as backwards
so i think we need to move forwards and
not
we need more discussion on it i think
there's some very good ideas i think
that perhaps a new amendment could be
crafted
but if the whole
enchilada is we just don't want a period
plain simple end it and end it and for
everybody
end it for everybody but nobody will do
that because that will hurt everybody's
constituents
and everybody's constituent will
rise up
if you really believe it's a subsidy do
you believe that i should subsidize my
neighbor because they have a solar panel
and at this end
but that won't happen so let's move
forward with a system we already have in
place
and help municipalities and everybody in
that municipality to advantage and and
be helped by lower rates
and
probably
it's not going to happen but i would
love to see us get another amendment
crafted and get some of the stakeholders
involved here
thank you
thank you mr chairman um
i think one of the goals of our
committee i believe should really be to
try to have
energy independence for our state
and that starts with looking at the
sources of energy that we can generate
in our own state and trying to keep a
diverse energy mix
uh that helps us locally
and
incidentally if we do nothing if we
decide we're gonna pass on all these
efforts whether it's
energy efficiency renewable energy net
metering all this stuff
don't think for one minute that that's
going to push down electric rates for
rate consistency it is going to do the
opposite everyone around us is pushing
down their demand therefore our
transmission costs will be going up
every year and your constituents
bills for electricity will be going up
every year so if you do nothing you are
actually pushing up electric bills for
everybody in this state that is the
option and we can say we don't like this
or that but that is going to be the
representative
since you raise a an interesting point
massachusetts our next door neighbor has
spent
far more than we have on
renewable energy on energy efficiency
and yet massachusetts has higher
electric rates than even california
uh
so
how do you how do you think
what makes you think
that um greater investments in renewable
energy and energy efficiency are
actually going to lower costs when that
hasn't been the case in massachusetts
well mr chairman first of all
you you and i both know that as many
people have expressed we are in a
transition we're in a transition from
fossil fuel dependency into a new era
which hasn't fully arrived yet and many
states are betting that that new
a new energy sources the renewable
energy sources are going to be the
future
that requires upfront costs
and that upfront cost as you mentioned
with the solar projects is pretty high
but but you also have to remember that
many of these renewable energy projects
the fuel costs are zero they're not
volatile they don't go up and down they
are zero once you install these
facilities solar wind
other projects
fuel costs will be contained in fact
they are contained at zero cost
so
but it is also true as we we all know
that
the transmission expenses for new
hampshire have been going up for the
last five or six years now whereas other
states around us their transmission
costs have been going down or as staying
flat that will continue to go up uh if
we don't do something that's true
and uh on the other hand many of these
other states around us the reason they
have more expensive
bills and maybe even rates is because
they are offering so many services to
their residents you know that that rate
that they paid down there that includes
free energy efficiency devices like
thermostats and light bulbs they get
that for free they don't get that for
free here in new hampshire because we're
a cheap skate state we we think we don't
want to spend any money now but what
you're doing is you're cutting off
investment for the future so okay if
that's what we want to do we're cutting
off opportunities for the future by
saving a little money right now that's
what's happening and uh i think that's
the reason we need to take action
representative platt mr chairman where
are we calling i've been sitting here
for
quite a while
we would not advance one moment in any
direction so i'd like to
see if we can control this
time to do that i think we
have had a good discussion on this issue
i don't sense that we're going to
achieve any kind of consensus today
i will hold on to this bill hb 106 for
the next week or so
before turning it over to the clerk
to
allow
us to think about this and see if we can
come up with uh see if anybody comes up
with
a bright idea that can allow us to move
this forward
um
so
as long as i hold on to the bill we can
still reconsider our motion to retain so
i will hold on to it for a week and
we'll see where we go from there
representative uh
partial do you have a comment
i'm an exactly uh uh sherman vos i just
wanted to thank you for allowing this
discussion today
i think it's to all of our benefit
examining these issues and
i truly appreciate it
very welcome
um
representative man did you have
something did you have your hand out
i did but i changed my mind i thought
the last comment was just fine sausage
yes uh thank you i'd like to thank you
mr chairman for doing
make giving us this opportunity
i just want to have a clarification
if we were to want to reconsider this
bill
we can't do it unless we have a formal
meeting
you just can't have it sitting around
and say hey maybe somebody wants to
reconsider it unless we have an
opportunity to reconsider it uh it's
it's not a
not a viable option
maybe i
wasn't
maybe i mis
misstated what i meant to say maybe i
didn't say it elegantly enough what i
meant was
i'll hold on to this bill for a week
and if somebody comes up with a
brilliant idea
that i think could allow us to come to a
consensus on this bill
let me know and what i will do is i will
arrange for us to have another meeting
it will have to be
a work session i suppose
uh
and i think a work session
may not have to be noticed for seven
days i think we may only have to notice
a work session for 24 days 24 hours so
we can probably get a meeting set up
fairly quickly of course that assumes
that we can find a room and a zoom
license
that's free but and that's always
problematic but
okay
anybody comes up with a brilliant idea
let me know
[Music]
thank you very much mr chairman okay
uh representative brasman thank you i
was just gonna add that we can also do a
straw poll over email if we need to
figure out if we want to
do anything further or not
yes representative resny suggested we
i'll have to think about that because it
might be a right to know violation
you're not supposed to use email for
full committee discussions of things
because it could be a right-to-know
violation but i'll i'll look into that
representative callie pitts oh i was
just going to say i don't think we can
do that by email
i think we have to do that in public so
and you already came up with that so i
and you know if we if we have a meeting
we decide hey we're just gonna go with
the you can take five minutes out of
your schedule to just do that by zone
okay thank you
i have one more thing that i'd like to
say to all of you before we leave there
was an excellent article in the
manchester union leader
on sunday about zoom fatigue
i saw it
fatigue is a real thing it's been
studied by researchers at stanford
university
and what they have discovered is that
if you do too much zoom
it
has a negative impact on you and they
actually have a list of tips
of things you can do during zoom
meetings to reduce your zoom fatigue and
one of the tips is to turn your video
off
so
and leave it for some period of time
because part of what creates zoom
fatigue is the idea that other people
are looking at you all the time
[Laughter]
so
well in my case it's me having to look
at myself
that's it
so
i just point this out and and suggest
that uh if you go on the union leader
website and search for that article on
zoom fatigue you might enjoy the reading
i know i did
and with that's an option to turn off
the video of like you viewing yourself
which i find really helpful because yeah
right
sorry to speak out of church just wanted
to share that all with you and i thank
you for a hard day's work
and um the next meeting will be at the
call of the chair
it'll probably be either to come up with
a resolution on hb 106 or to
hear some senate bills one of the other
so
until then i'll bid you all to do and uh
wish you a good week and a good weekend
and we'll see you next time thanks
thank you all thanks
bye